Ich weiß, komische
Uhrzeit. Normalerweise bin ich entweder
früher oder später am Start.
Aber nachdem ich
Urlaub hab,
Sache ist bloß die, ich weiß nicht, ob von euch jetzt viele
da sind. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber ich glaub, die meisten sind fertig arbeiten,
sind schon auf dem Weg heim oder so. Michael,
fünf Spieljahre, Naumeter am Start. Nice.
Um nicht zu sagen,
Nice.
Excellent.
So. Irgendwas stimmt
mit meinem Headset nicht. Moment, ich muss es mal kurz abmachen.
Herr Schlocker!
Danke für den Prime Sub.
Wartet mal, ich kurz Headset raus machen.
So, jetzt bin ich
wieder da. Übrigens, Franzosen
scheint das Wort Poggers zu
verwirren, denn, wartet mal.
Morgen, KS, Alter.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, Franzosen scheint das Wort Poggers
zu verwirren, weil
ich hab mir einen Char gemacht in einem
MMO, der Poggers heißt.
Da hab ich mit ein paar Franzosen gespielt
und die haben im Teamspeak die ganze
Zeit gesagt, Pogger, Pogger.
Die konnten
Poggers nicht sagen.
Pogger, Pogger.
Pogger.
Wenn nicht im TS, im Discord,
Alter, hab ich TS gesagt.
Backweight, Alter.
Nein, nein, ganz so oldschool,
das ist TS, das ist auch nicht mehr.
Pogger, haben die gesagt, Pogger.
Der Frage, werden wir heute
nachgehen, ob es wirklich so
kacke gewesen ist, weil ich habe
zufälligerweise
bei mir eine Windows ME ISO
gefunden. Wenn man dort
die MD5 Summen kontrolliert, wird man auch
feststellen, das ist ein originales
Windows ME ISO ohne
großartigen, äh, was heißt ohne großartigen,
ohne gar keine Änderungen, sonst hätt's nicht
den passenden Hashwert.
Das hab ich
zufälligerweise
bei mir
gefunden. Da hab ich mir gedacht,
wir probieren das mal aus dem Dachboden.
Ja, genau. Das ISO-File
hab ich vom Dachboden geholt, korrekt, korrekt.
Backweight.
Mit Key.
Ey, ein Windows 5, äh,
Windows 5, Alter, was erzähl ich?
Windows ME Key hab ich tatsächlich
noch. Ich hab auch noch ein Windows
95 und Windows 98 Key.
Ich hab sogar noch irgendwo
das originale
Windows 98 SE Handbuch.
Ja, Key hab ich,
Key hab ich auch. Wir probieren das
heute mal aus, weil, also,
der Hintergrund ist folgendes. Erstens
hab ich irgendwie übelst Bock, mal wieder ein altes
Windows zu installieren. Nicht, weil's
irgendwie für irgendwas
brauchbar wäre. Und das zweite
ist, ich würde gerne mal
das hier ausprobieren. Das ist richtiges
High-IQ-Projekt. Und zwar
GitHub Browser
Service.
Äh.
Wenn ich noch Browser Service,
wenn ich noch richtig suchen könnte.
Da kann man nämlich,
mit einem Proxy
neue Webseiten
im Internet Explorer 6 anzeigen
lassen. Das funktioniert
folgendermaßen. Man installiert sich was auf
einer Linux-Kiste
und trägt das dann als Proxy in
Internet Explorer ein.
Und unter der Haube
rendert das
quasi die Linux-Kiste und
schickt das dann mit ein bisschen JavaScript rüber
als Bilddateien
in den Internet Explorer.
Das wollte ich schon immer mal ausprobieren.
Das ist eigentlich auch so ein komplett unsinniges
Stück Software, aber cool, dass es funktioniert.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, wenn wir das schon mal
eh ausprobieren, also hier oben sieht man
eine Proxy-Adresse.
Wenn wir das eh schon ausprobieren,
dann können wir das auch mal so machen.
Als Bild, ja.
Ja, ein Video könnte, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob der Internet Explorer 6 in irgendeiner Art
und Weise Videos kann.
Wahrscheinlich GIFs, wobei GIFs
ja nicht wirklich als Video durchgehen, oder?
Mario, da habe ich schon von den Sub.
Leute, gehen GIFs,
als Video durch, ja oder nein?
Also ich finde, GIFs
gehen nicht als Video durch, weil
für mich, also es gibt zwei Sachen,
die für mich Videos ausmachen.
Erstens, sagen wir mal,
mehr als 5 FPS,
wobei, man muss sagen,
mehr als 5 FPS, das geht ja
mittlerweile, wobei das nicht, das nicht wirklich,
aber der hier zum Beispiel, guckt mal,
der hier hat definitiv mehr als
5 FPS, guckt mal, guckt mal, wie flüssig
der dancet. Also der hat
mehr als, also für mich machen,
Videos aus, erst mal mehr als 5 FPS
und vor allem machen Videos aus,
also moderne Videos, encodete
Videos aus, dass die eben nicht
Bild für Bild gespeichert werden müssen,
sondern eben als Bild-Deferenz
zu unterschiedlichen Keyframes und das ist
es ja soweit, ich weiß bei GIF nicht.
Deswegen ist die Frage, gehen GIFs
als Videos durch oder nicht?
Wenn ich jetzt sagen würde,
GIFs sind nur bewegte Bilder,
würde dir sagen, ja Max, aber jedes Video
sind nur bewegte Bilder.
Also ich finde,
also ich finde, GIFs gehen nicht als Video durch,
auch wenn sie animiert
sind, aber
Video ist was anderes.
Ja, wir können es mit GIFs coole Sachen
machen, ja, wie zum Beispiel transparent
im Hintergrund und sowas, das kannst du ja beispielsweise
mit H.264
bis heute nicht machen, da musst du
irgendwelche ollen anderen Formate
verwenden.
Ja, für sowas
ist es tatsächlich sinnvoll, zum Beispiel
es gibt ja Leute, die wollen sich
so eine richtig Oldschool
Spielekiste hinstellen
oder sowas
und keine Ahnung, wirklich
Windows 98, Windows 95 oder so drauf
oder Windows ME
oder XP oder so, wobei
XP, gibt es einen halbwegs
aktuellen Firefox noch für Windows XP?
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ne.
Ich glaube, das ist alles
eingestellt.
Ich glaube, den letzten
Firefox, den es für Windows XP gab,
der ist bestimmt auch schon gut und gern 5, 6 Jahre alt.
Wahrscheinlich eher
6, 7 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Sonst habe ich gedacht, wir probieren das aus.
Ja, es gibt noch den alten Opera,
den gibt es noch, den als es noch
nicht China-Chinesen-Opera war.
Also nicht
Our-Data-Now-Opera war.
Ja, aber selbst der,
also der letzte
richtige Opera-Opera,
selbst der hat ja Probleme damit,
moderne Webseiten anzuzeigen.
Eis fliegt, danke für den Sub.
Ich meine, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass Facebook,
wenn du es neu aufmachst,
glaube ich, beim allerersten Mal,
irgendwie, ich glaube, irgendwie 27 MB
insgesamt verteilt über mehrere Requests
JavaScript oder so runterlädt.
Hat doch mal letztens einer
irgendwo analysiert.
27 MB JavaScript.
Also es gibt nicht ein fettes
JavaScript-File, so ist es nicht.
Also ich dürfte mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das
irgendwie einen Download macht, da irgendwie 27 MB.
Aber wenn du das alles zusammenrechnest,
was das einbindet,
Tracking-Zeug, User-Interface-Zeug,
braucht Facebook irgendwie erstmal 27
MB-Kram,
dass es so ein bisschen mehr ist.
Überhaupt gedenkt zu laufen.
Und das wird bei,
das wird wahrscheinlich bei Instagram
oder den anderen Dingern nicht
viel anders sein.
Das Gute ist, dass das mit der
Zeit alles gecached ist.
Wir können ja schon mal die VM erstellen, wenn wir
gerade schon dabei sind.
Zufällig bei mir gespawnt hier auf dem Desktop,
die Windows ME ISO.
Wir haben ja noch ein Windows 11 laufen, warum?
Was das da macht, weiß ich nicht.
Und wir haben hier noch
Rock Smog,
Stinger laufen.
Die kann ich eigentlich mal löschen, oder?
Die Rock Smog, Stinger, die braucht doch
eigentlich gar keiner mehr.
Open Directory.
Machines. Ja, das löschen wir jetzt mal.
Hier.
Wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind.
Remove.
Weil die brauchen, werden wir nie wieder für irgendwas
verwenden. Das war mal zum Ausprobieren.
Das war's.
Wofür die Windows XP Geschichte hier ist.
Wie groß ist denn der Müll?
24 GB.
Was haben wir denn damit gemacht?
Hat noch irgendjemand einen Plan, warum wir hier Windows 11 installiert hatten?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Zumindest kann es nicht so akut sein.
Wo sage ich der Papierkorb hier?
Ich hasse dieses neue Menü hier oben.
Das ist so nervig, Alter.
Ich habe eh keine Ahnung, was an dem Menü jetzt so schlecht gewesen ist.
Ich meine, es sieht vielleicht nicht super krass 2023 Bleeding Edge aus,
aber sieht Windows an sich eh nicht.
Und es verhaut sich nicht.
Und ist vor allem super zerstückelt.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel, das können wir übrigens jetzt gleich unter Windows ME uns angucken.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel für zerstückelte Sachen in Windows ist ja immer das hier.
Also nicht das Menü, das auch.
Ja, das auch.
Mein Lieblingsding, was ich immer gerne zeige, ist das hier.
Ich würde sagen, 16x16 Icons.
Also das ist so ein wildes Zusammenhang.
Ein zusammengewürfelter Krempel aus 40 Jahren Windows.
Und vor allem, man muss auch mal ehrlich sagen, die meisten dieser Icons hier,
Die meisten dieser Icons hier, auch die neuen, die sehen einfach richtig scheiße aus.
Die sehen einfach richtig ecke aus.
Die sehen einfach richtig kelle aus.
Also anscheinend möchte niemand seine Ordner Icons unter Windows kustomisieren.
Gut, unter Windows möchtest du ja eh nichts mehr customizen, weil du ja eigentlich so gut wie nichts mehr customizen kannst.
Ich meine, du kannst ja nicht mehr mehr einen Ordner auf die Taskleiste ziehen.
Was ich euch gleich zeigen werde, Hexenwerk in Windows ME ging das.
Ob man es glaubt oder nicht, aber die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da, Leute.
Legen wir mal ein neues VM an.
So, next, next.
Ich hoffe, dass es überhaupt noch VMware-Tools gibt für Windows ME und sowas.
Hyper-V unsupported.
Habe ich auch nicht vor VMware, macht dir keine Gedanken.
Windows ME, Windows ME.
Number of Processors.
Chat gibt, wie viele CPUs konnte Windows ME?
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das Ding konnte genau eine CPU und einen Core, fertig.
Mehr ging damals nicht.
Für alles andere hast du Windows NT oder Windows 2000.
Windows 2000 war es damals wahrscheinlich eher schon gebraucht.
Ich glaube, mehr ging nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
Wir gucken.
Gucken wir mal, was passiert.
How many cores supported Windows ME?
Das Windows ME support dual processors.
Nope.
Best bet is Windows 2000.
Ja, dachte ich mir.
Es gibt kein Multi-Core-Support, Multi-CPU-Support in Windows ME.
Aber das hatte ich auch irgendwo noch im Hinterkopf.
Dein erster PC hat Windows ME.
Ganz ehrlich?
Ich bin nämlich der Meinung.
Bis jetzt zumindest gewesen, dass Windows ME nicht so kacke ist, wie es immer dargestellt wird.
Ich meine, Windows ME war kein großer Schritt von Windows 98 aus.
Aber Windows ME hat ein paar coole Sachen.
Unter anderem die Optik, die ein bisschen moderner damals ausgesehen hat als Windows 98.
Windows ME hatte, glaube ich, als allererstes so Consumer Windows.
ICS.
Kennt ihr noch Windows ICS?
Wer weiß noch, was das ist?
Das war das...
Das war das Windows Internet Connection Sharing, ICS.
Das konntest du quasi, wenn du...
Damals hatte man dann auch ganz gerne DSL-Modems, direkt an der Kiste dran angeschlossen.
Und damals konnte man zum Beispiel, wenn man ICS eingeschaltet hat, konnte man quasi ganz normal so ein bisschen auf NAT-Router machen mit seinem Windows ME.
Ja, Internet Connection Sharing hieß das damals.
Das war, glaube ich, bei Windows ME neu.
Und ich habe das ausführlichst benutzt.
Äh, ICS ist...
Das könnte auch Kalendern hat, heißt aber, das Internet Connection Sharing war das damals.
So, also, komm, wir hauen jetzt mal richtig rein.
1000, Moment, was, Maximum?
Okay, Maximum RAM supported Windows ME.
Irgendwie hat die Musik einfach random aufgehört gerade.
Ich mag das nicht, wenn die Playlists so random sind.
Also mit random, also so unterschiedlich laut.
Das ist immer anstrengend.
Das Beste hier.
Pinguinstrecke.
Äh, genau, ich wollte eigentlich gucken, was das Maximum an RAM ist.
Maximum RAM supported Windows ME.
Was das ist.
Ein Gigabyte, was? Limitations?
Wie jetzt?
Okay, ich stelle mal ein Gigabyte ein.
Äh, ja, ein Gig RAM ein.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Mehr geht nicht?
Gucken wir mal.
Ich meine, das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass er schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht mehr erkennt.
Next.
Lassen wir es gleich ins Internet?
Ich bin ja skeptisch, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, ich meine, was soll großartig passieren?
Der connectet irgendwelche offiziellen Microsoft-Sachen.
Also, das ist nicht so wild.
So, next.
Next.
8 Gig.
Ich glaube, 8 Gigabyte Disk war damals riesig groß.
Das sollte reichen für alles, was man so.
vorhat.
Updates.
Stimmt, wie macht...
Gab das eigentlich für Windows ME einen Service-Pack?
Gab's der SP1 oder sowas?
Windows ME Update CD Release 2.2.
Ich glaube eher nicht, ey.
Stimmt, wie updatet man?
Wie hat man eigentlich damals seine Betriebssysteme geupdatet?
Also, ich meine, ich weiß, es gab damals ein Windows Update Service.
Da konntest du damals auch...
Das ging dann nur im Internet Explorer.
Musstest du auf die Windows.
Auf die Windows-Seite und so.
Aber, wie hat man das, wie hat man das ohne Internet-Connections damals gemacht?
Gab's dann...
Ja gut, doch, doch, klar.
Damals hat man, damals hat man sich dann die aktuelle PC-Welt oder Chip oder, oder, oder...
Ich glaube, die CT hatte damals auch keine, hatte damals auch keine CDs dabei.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Ähm, gekauft und hat sich dann die aktuellen Service-Packs installiert.
Okay, also, was haben wir denn hier?
Soundkarte, so, erst mal.
Let's go.
Äh...
How to update Windows ME.
Das würde mich echt mal interessieren.
Hier.
Der erklärt uns das.
Updates für Windows ME im Jahr 2022.
Kannst du Windows ME noch verwenden?
Vielleicht nicht als Tagesfahrer.
Ich habe das Gefühl, hier ist irgendwie der Browser der Meinung, er muss das mit Daily Driver, mit Tages...
Tagesfahrer übersetzen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen die Beschreibung...
Auf Deutsch übersetzt werden muss, man weiß es nicht so genau, aber merkt euch, als Tagesfahrer eignet sich Windows ME nicht.
Da wäre ich aber auch so nicht drauf gekommen.
Also, wo haben wir denn hier unser ISO?
Musik ist mir schon wieder zu relaxing, Alter.
Egal, lassen wir jetzt.
Wo haben wir denn die CD?
Use ISO Image.
Ließ sich der Kram damals installieren ohne CD-Key, dass man sagen konnte, ich aktiviere später?
Ne, ich glaube, das ging nicht.
Da muss man bei der Installation, musste man zwangsläufig einen CD-Key eingeben.
So Boot, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Boot from harddisk.
Nein, ganz bestimmt nicht.
Stretch.
Excellent.
sketch
Moment, habe ich jetzt gesagt stretch keep aspect ratio so rum?
Dude, find CD.
Keep aspect ratio so rum.
So, also.
Boot from CD.
Was haben wir denn zur Auswahl?
Start windows setup, start computer mit CD-ROM Support.
Start computer Ohne CD-ROM.
Start Windows Setup with CD-ROM support.
Start Windows Setup with CD-ROM, I would say start Windows Setup from CD-ROM.
Name of the Trip.
presumably upbound.
Total optim imagining minutes now.
Win, asked through E bile 이런 E le di do it, performance.
Page hold it down now und the process is still not progressing.
Geht einfach gar nicht weiter.
Das Funst.
Dieses blaue Setup-Ding.
Das hatten die gefühlt auch 30 Jahre, oder?
Was macht denn F5?
Äh.
Jetzt habe ich die Color removed.
Und weiter.
Okay, man kann nur die Color removen.
Die Color wieder einschalten geht nicht.
Das ist auch Microsoft-Logik, äh.
Ich drücke jetzt weiter.
F5 geht nicht mehr an.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich Exit mache?
Dann startet er wahrscheinlich einfach neu, hä?
Moment, was?
Press F3.
Oh!
Moment, Moment.
Wir sind unter DOS, Alter.
Massive.
DOS-Prompt.
Da muss man jetzt einfach Setup machen, ja?
Setup.
Äh.
Okay.
Reboot.
Shutdown.
Ähm.
Check.
Okay.
Ich weiß.
Ich kann es einfach über die VM neu starten.
Wie würde man denn jetzt normalerweise ein DOS rebooten?
Weiß das irgendjemand von euch noch?
Also es ist weder Reboot noch How-to-Reboot-DOS.
Ja, super.
Auf die Idee wäre ich auch gekommen.
Über die VM neu starten.
You can use Shutdown.
Haben die doch Shutdown hier.
Shut.
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Windows.
Komm, burscht.
Send Control alt entfernen.
Okay.
Gut ist.
Boot.
Boot from CD.
Start Windows Setup.
Ja, so moderne Sachen wie ein Reboot-Command, das gab's nicht.
Also die Musik ist mir auch zu relaxing.
Haben wir denn noch irgendwas?
Irgendwas, was soll ich dazu?
Holiday Nintendo Tunes.
Okay.
Excellent.
Das heißt aber, es ist ein bisschen was Weihnachtliches.
So.
Okay.
Setup Windows.
Press Enter.
Wir pressen Enter.
Und dann können wir noch was machen.
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich sage Nein?
Sagt er wahrscheinlich, es geht nicht.
Ja, okay.
Es macht jetzt relativ wenig Sinn.
Okay.
You have a drive over 5...
Oh, High-End-Rechner, Leute.
Über 512 MB Festplatte.
Was war die kleinste Festplatte, die ihr jemals hattet, Leute?
Ich meine wirklich in den Händen hatte, aber nicht in den Händen.
Händen hattet, nicht benutzt habt.
Die kleinste Festplatte, die ihr je in den Fingern hattet.
16 MB? Okay.
32 MB.
Ja, bei mir war es auch so in dem Dreh.
Ich glaube, meine war 10,
aber ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es 10 überhaupt
gab. Deswegen vermute ich auch mal
16. Das war so ein richtig
olles, fettes IBM-Ding.
Das war so ein Backstein.
Das war ein richtig dicker Backstein,
die Festplatte.
Er möchte von uns, dass wir
Large Disk Support
enablen.
Wollen wir nicht so sein, wir enablen
Large Disk Support.
Und die kleinste Festplatte,
die ich je benutzt habe,
die müsste wahrscheinlich 0,8
Gig gewesen sein.
Mein allererster
PC? Oder hatte der noch weniger?
Ich glaube, der hatte
0,8 Gig.
Oder sogar
1,2 Gig schon.
Weil
ich kann mich erinnern damals,
wir haben den Rechner gekauft
mit 8 MB RAM
und ich glaube 0,8
Gig Disk. Und als
wir den Rechner dann eingeschaltet haben,
waren es 16 MB RAM
und 1,2 Gig Disk.
Die haben uns quasi den Rechner
die Nummer zu groß
gegeben. Dann haben die sich vertan.
Haben wir uns natürlich gefreut.
Und nix gesagt.
Äh, okay.
Hä?
Warum rebootet der jetzt, um Large Disk Support
einzuschalten? Und vor allem, woher weiß er
nach dem Reboot noch, dass Large Disk Support
eingeschaltet ist? Muss ich jetzt von der
Festplatte booten oder von CD?
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich von
Festplatte boote.
Nix. Nice.
Wieder von CD.
Ja, ich dachte auch von...
Ich hätte jetzt auch gedacht von der Festplatte, aber...
Nein, nein, nein, nein. So einfach ist das in der Microsoft-Logik
nicht. Kann ich einfach
jetzt von Festplatte... Siehste?
Easy. Jetzt wird einfach ohne Rückfrage
BAM, C formatiert.
So muss das sein.
Wisst ihr, bei jedem Scheiß kommt irgendeine
Abfrage. Wollen sie jetzt nicht
vielleicht exiten? Wollen sie jetzt nicht vielleicht
zurück? Aber beim Festplatten
formatieren. Also da, wo es tatsächlich
mal sinnvoll wäre, eine Abfrage zu machen...
Nein, das ist einfach
reboot, BAM, Festplatte überschrieben.
Wobei überschrieben.
Es ist ja nicht überschrieben. Das ist ja einfach nur
Quick-Format gewesen, ohne zu überschreiben.
Aber das ist...
Ich hatte damals schon immer das
Gefühl, dass
das wirkte
auch schon während der Installation alles
super fragil irgendwie.
Windows-Dreck und Trommel. So,
next.
C-Doppelpunkt Windows. Recommended.
Mir war nicht bewusst, dass ich das überhaupt
irgendwo anders hinmachen könnte. Und
vor allem, warum möchte man sein Windows-Verzeichnis
irgendwo anders hinmachen?
Next.
Das war wahrscheinlich echt eine ganz blöde
Idee, das woanders hinzumachen.
Es gab bestimmt genug Programme, die das
hardcoded drinnen hatten, C-Doppelpunkt Windows.
Setup will take
30 zu 60 Minutes.
Die...
Das ging jetzt instant erstmal runter.
Aber die... Also ich tippe,
die Installation dauert zwei Minuten am Ende.
Ja.
Windows XP habe ich... Also ich habe
tatsächlich Windows XP
und vor allem Windows 98.
Habe ich so oft neu installiert.
Ich konnte damals mein Windows... Das ist
ungelogen, Leute. Ohne Spaß,
wie der Asitoni gesagt hätte.
Ich konnte meinen Windows-CD-Key
auswendig...
Noch irgendwelche Windows-CD-Key-Enjoyers
hier, die das... Also ich habe so oft
mein Windows neu installiert. Ich wusste meinen Windows-CD-Key
komplett auswendig.
Ich konnte das blind eintippen.
So oft habe ich neu installiert.
Waren das nicht...
Waren das nicht die geleakten Keys,
die so angefangen haben?
FFC-KGW?
Die Super-Legit-Keys?
Haben die nicht so angefangen?
Und ihr wisst ja, das allererste,
was man gemacht hat...
Oder Chat-Gil.
Ich weiß, man macht sowas heute nicht mehr.
Aber damals, als man sich da noch
zusammen getroffen hat
und entweder noch
per BNC-Kabel oder
schon, wenn man ein bisschen moderner war,
hatte man dann einen Switch und A45-Stecker
und Netzwerkkarten und sowas.
Als man sich da zusammengestöpselt hat...
Damals hat man dann so Sachen wie Half-Life-1-Multiplayer
und sowas gespielt.
Es ging aber immer irgendwas nicht.
Immer ging irgendwas nicht.
Und was war die erste Reaktion
da drauf, wenn etwas nicht ging?
Ihr werdet euch jetzt nach der Einleitung
schon denken können, aber vielleicht kennen das
die ein oder andere noch von euch.
Was war das erste, was man...
Richtig, das allererste, was man gemacht hat,
ist erstmal rechnen...
Reboot, ne, ja auch, auch mehrfach.
Das erste, was man immer gemacht hat,
erstmal die ersten paar Stunden
Windows neu installiert.
Immer Windows neu installiert.
Jedes Mal. Das haben alle erst am Anfang
Windows neu installiert.
Und du musstest dann damals in die Windows-Settings,
wobei, das zeige ich euch.
Das zeige ich euch gleich.
Lasst uns das mal merken.
Also, Custom.
Was gibt es hier alles dabei?
Ah, das brauchen wir unbedingt.
Ganz wichtig.
Briefcase.
Absolut keine Ahnung, was wir damit machen sollen.
Desktop-Wallpapers. Ganz wichtig.
Mauspointers. Exzellent.
Also, wie soll ich denn ohne...
Guck mal, und die brauchen noch 0,0 MB Speicherplatz.
Und der Calculator.
Das ist auch am Start.
Addressbook. Communications.
Dial-Up-Networking.
Dial-Up-Server.
Was? Ach, da konnten sich andere
in einem Modem auf deinem
Windows 95 Zeug einwählen.
Boah, das ist ja super abgedreht gewesen.
Hyper-Terminal.
Ja, war das sowas wie
Telnet?
Was, da war noch mehr beim ersten Punkt?
Wie war noch mehr hier?
Oh, da fehlt...
7 von 8 selected.
Ach, da geht's...
Screensaver. Ja, selbstverständlich.
Additional Screensavers.
Essentiell.
Komplett essential.
Hyper-Terminal.
War das sowas wie Telnet?
Direct Cable Connection.
Das war 0 Modem.
Kabel.
Internet Connection Sharing.
Da ist es doch manchmal.
Eine ICS, Leute.
ICS.
MSN Messenger Service.
Natürlich, den brauchen wir unbedingt.
Net Meeting.
Net Meeting, Alter.
Wisst ihr das Net Meeting?
Das Programm war,
wo ich zum allerersten Mal
in meinem Leben Buba gesehen hab.
Ja, ich weiß, Opa Max erzählt
vom Krieg.
Ähm, Net Meeting ist so ein bisschen
der Vorgänger...
Net Meeting ist ein bisschen der Vorgänger
von Teams, so kann man sich das vorstellen.
Oder eher von Skype.
Eher von Skype.
Da konnte man damals
online telefonieren mit Webcam und alles.
Und es gab damals schon
Seiten mit
ähm...
Ja, irgendwelchen
Porn-Geschichten.
Das war aber damals noch ein bisschen anders.
Das funktionierte damals so,
du hattest online, also konntest dich connecten dahin.
Und hab ich natürlich mit nem Freund aus der Schule,
nach der Schule, hab ich das da gemacht.
Net Meeting auf, sie irgendwohin connectet oder so.
Und da hast du dann im Prinzip irgendwelche Mädels gehabt,
so mit 200x200 Bild und 2 FPS und sowas.
Gab's damals schon, Leute.
Glaubt mir, das ist älter als ihr denkt.
Ja, dass es sowas schon gibt.
Und das Ding war halt,
die konnten das damals nicht darüber anhören.
Und das war halt,
Und das war halt, die konnten das damals nicht darüber anhören.
Und da konntest du dann
quasi sagen, äh,
boah, hier, äh,
ich bin so heiß auf dich
oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und dann hat die dann geantwortet mit,
ja, dann ruf doch die 0190 Nummer an,
dann kannst du mit mir telefonieren und sowas.
Das war richtig, das war eigentlich super krasser Scam, ja.
Wir haben natürlich nicht angerufen, ganz so blöd waren wir nicht.
Aber wir haben dann immer versucht, über diese,
gab's halt so Listen mit Sachen, wo du dich verbinden kannst zu Net Meeting.
Irgendwie, da irgendwie,
noch was zu erhaschen, was man gesehen hat, ja.
Net Meeting, Mann, meine Güte.
Damals waren wir wahrscheinlich so,
lass mal überlegen,
ich bin 1984 geboren,
da war ich wahrscheinlich 15 oder sowas, ja.
14, 15?
Ja, da probiert man so Dinge aus, ne.
Universal Plug & Play.
Unbedingt.
VPN, auch ganz wichtig.
Brauchen wir unbedingt alles, alles drauf.
Desktop-Themes, alles.
Warum ist Communications immer noch nicht alles an?
Games.
Multi-Language-Support.
Ah ja, krieg ich das vielleicht dann auch in Deutsch?
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Es gibt nur Baltic, Central European,
Albanisch, Tschechisch, Kroatisch.
Gibt's vielleicht nicht, gibt's vielleicht auch Deutsch?
Weil die Microsoft-Übersetzungen waren immer schon
waren schon immer ganz besonders toll
auf Deutsch damals.
Millenniums-Edition.
Okay, gibt's nicht.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch standardmäßig mit dabei.
Was die Beschreibung war, VPN?
Moment, wo?
Wo?
Das ist so laggy, die Maus hier drinnen.
Virtual Private Networking
provides secure connections
to private networks across public networks
such as the Internet.
Wieso, ist doch richtig.
Ist doch vollkommen okay, was da steht.
Ich mein, immerhin
taucht das Wort Internet schon auf.
Multimedia.
Makromedia Shockwave Flash.
Ganz wichtig.
Multimedia Sound.
Sound Sample, Sound Recorder, alles.
Media Player.
Gib ihm alles drauf.
Online Services.
Prodigy Internet, Earthlink.
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört.
AT&T kennt man, AOL
kennt man auch.
Sag mal, es gibt doch
heute bestimmt noch immer noch
Dial-Up Internet, oder?
Ich müsste mal echt probieren,
ob man, ich hab noch mein altes
56K Modem hier.
Ob man ernsthaft
heute noch Dial-Up Modem machen kann?
Clipboard Viewer.
Compressed Followers, Network
Assisted Monitor, alles an.
Alles an.
WebTV für Windows.
Installs Web...
Oh, das ist ein richtig krasses
neues Feature, das kenn ich nicht.
WebTV für Windows.
Das funktioniert bestimmt immer noch
30 Jahre später ganz toll.
Next.
Computer Name.
Werk Group, juckt eh kein.
Select Language.
German.
Leute, ich will mir mal die beste
Microsoft Übersetzung, die es gibt.
German.
Select Country Region.
Dann machen wir auch Germany.
Uganda.
Über...
Die Technologie ist einfach
nicht da heutzutage.
Wisst ihr, dass das beim aktuellen
Windows Setup nicht funktioniert?
Dass ihr hier unten irgendwo seid,
in der Liste, und den Startbuchstaben
drückt und dann springt er da hin?
Das geht im aktuellen Windows Setup nicht mehr.
Germany.
Select your Keyboard Layout. Nein.
Nein, nein, nein. Keyboard Layout ist
German Standard.
Und Zeitzone ist
äh...
Berlin.
Next.
23 Minuten dauert es jetzt.
Es ging ganz schön schnell.
Die Zeit von 60 runter auf 23.
Finish.
Windows just got better.
Das ist so schnell, das können wir gar nicht lesen.
Hundreds of
enhancement and new features.
Features based on customer requests
and product support experiences.
Cutting edge technology.
Best support for your current
hardware and programs.
Gut, kann man sich jetzt drüber lustig machen,
ist aber Blödsinn. Ich meine, das ist halt 30 Jahre alt.
Aber cutting edge connects you to the web.
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Gleich machen wir den Internet Explorer auf.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich auch erstmal noch
TCP, IP und DHCP und so einschalten,
dass ich überhaupt eine IP krieg.
Cutting edge technology.
Windows Media Player 7.
Windows, ich hab immer noch das Gefühl,
21 Minuten wirst du nicht brauchen,
bis du installiert hast.
Improved, Alter, das geht so schnell,
das kannst du echt nicht lesen, man.
Easy to update.
Web based updating.
Na, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus,
web based updating.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Guck mal, er denkt immer noch, dass es 21 Minuten dauert.
Register your copy.
Ah, okay, sorry Leute, 20 Minuten.
Eindeutig, mit dem Restart sind es nur noch 20 Minuten.
Logisch.
Obviously.
Das hängt.
Leute, ich mach lieber nix.
Finger weg.
Ah, jetzt sind es übrigens nur noch 10 Minuten.
Das wirkte damals schon so super
krass fragil, auch schon während der Installation.
Ich hatte immer Schiss, dass es hängen bleibt.
Kann sich auch noch einer dran erinnern?
Die Windows Installation war ja auch damals
ein bisschen wählerig, die blieb manchmal hängen.
Und der hatte einfach nix mehr gemacht,
dann musstest du neu starten, irgendwann ging's dann wieder.
Ich hatte immer Schiss,
dass der während der Installation hängen blieb.
Das ist ja auch keine Möglichkeit rauszubekommen,
woran es liegt, dass der hängen bleibt.
Ich hatte so oft, dass es einfach
random hängen geblieben ist während der Installation.
Und es hing dann halt.
Hat nichts weiter gemacht.
Okay, non plug and play
hardware wird detected.
Ist ME die private
Version von 2000? Ne.
Windows ME ist das letzte Windows
quasi DOS
Windows, was es gegeben hat.
Also quasi das letzte der originalen
Windows Linie.
Windows 2000
ist Windows NT
Linie gewesen.
Also sprich, mit Windows ME war dann Schluss.
Ich meine, es war ja im Prinzip
Windows 1
ob es Windows 2 gab, bin ich mir
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher.
Windows 1, Windows 3, Windows 3.11
Windows
95, Windows 98
Windows ME.
Bei den anderen hattest du glaube ich Windows NT
3.5
3.5.1
3.5.8
3.5.2
3.5.3
3.5.6
3.5.7
3.5.8
3.5.9
3.5.11
Ich tippe jetzt mal kurz schnell ein.
Hoffentlich habe ich...
Oh, nice.
Der hat sogar deutsche Tastatur-Layout.
Leute, wisst ihr was?
Das ist auch was, was unter Windows 11 nicht funktioniert.
Wenn du unter Windows 11 in der Installation deutsches Tastatur-Layout auswählst,
dann musst du nochmal deutsches Tastatur-Layout nach der Installation auswählen.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Completed.
Ja, und keine Keys im Chat.
Sonst Mod-Check.
Und jetzt...
Ah, Restart.
Zehn Minuten immer noch, Leute.
Boah, die Maus...
Alter, die Maus leckt so krass da drin rum.
Okay, er ist wieder am Start.
Ah, er muss ja noch meine Hardware upsetten.
Alles klar.
Setup.
Nicht upsetten.
Windows is now set.
Okay, let's go.
Windows, mach einfach.
Gib ihm.
Seht ihr immer noch die alten Dateifade mit über acht Zeichen und so?
Mit Tilde und so drin?
Das sind auch so die DOS-Überbleibsel.
Updating System Settings.
Component Progress.
Overall Progress.
Okay, das ist wirklich langsamer, als ich dachte.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das alles durch Single-Threading und vielen Sleeps beschränkt.
Die haben...
Das Windows-Installations-Ding, das besteht bestimmt zur Hälfte aus Sleeps.
Dass sie auch sicher sind, dass was fertig ist und sowas.
Das hat bestimmt Race Conditions ohne Ende.
Und das haben sie alles mit Sleeps gefixt.
War da nicht noch FAT drunter?
Klar, FAT 32 ist das jetzt.
Können wir gleich mal gucken, was ich für ein Dateisystem hab.
Boah, das ist wirklich langsamer, als ich gedacht hab.
Aber jetzt nur noch sieben Minuten.
Die Windows 10-Installation geht schneller.
Ich glaube, es nimmt sich gar nicht mal so viel.
Windows 10 und Windows 11, die faken auch viel rum mit.
Es lädt jetzt einen neuen Bildschirm und das überbrückt dann wieder zwei Minuten und sowas.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist 2 und 3 Bit.
Aber du konntest ohne Probleme 16-Bit-Programme ausführen.
Ich find's auch toll, dass er gar nicht so wirklich anzeigt, was er eigentlich macht.
Updating System Settings.
Component Progress.
Overall Progress.
Man hat ehrlich gesagt...
Guck mal.
Diese Progress-Bars, die sind komplett unsinnig, weil du überhaupt nicht weißt, was er macht.
Also was ist der Sinn davon, dass es hier überhaupt durchläuft?
Willst du jetzt zählen, bei wieviel mal durchlaufender ist oder wie?
Aber Microsoft liebt halt einfach Progress-Bars.
Das haben wir schon oft an vielen Stellen gesehen.
Warum eigentlich?
Das weiß ich nicht, warum.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die gelernt haben, dass die Leute sonst Angst haben, wenn sich nicht permanent was bewegt, dass es kaputt ist.
Und die Angst war ja damals auch berechtigt, dass was kaputt ist.
Wie oft mir das Windows-Setup einfach random hängen geblieben ist.
Okay, so sah also der Login-Bildschirm aus.
Da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal schauen.
Prage, Chat, prage.
Dass...
Wir uns überhaupt...
Dass es überhaupt noch Veränder-Tools gibt.
Und...
Da sind wir.
Wir testen nicht Windows ME.
Testen kann man das nicht, ne?
Okay, hier kann man nichts umstellen.
Also Veränder-Tools jetzt.
Die Lade-Trommel.
Wisst ihr, ich hab damals immer gedacht, wenn man eine Soundkarte hätte, dann würde man das Trommeln hören.
Was aber Blödsinn ist.
Das trommelt nie.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen.
Install for Android-Tools.
Prage, dass das funktioniert.
Wow, wow.
Instant.
Web-TV für Windows.
Okay, lassen wir uns das gleich angucken.
Ja, äh...
Was gibt's denn da zur Auswahl?
Okay, Typik.
Typisch ist alles.
Nice.
Sehr gutes Installationsprogramm, vor allem, ja.
Yes.
Äh.
Blue Screen.
An Eject Request was received for a drive that is in use.
Continue with...
Moment.
Habe ich nicht eingestellt, dass ich es auf Deutsch benutzen will?
Chatge.
Ich habe doch ausgewählt, dass ich es auf Deutsch haben will.
Gibt's nicht.
Ja, damals wurde prinzipiell alles autorunned, was eingelegt wurde.
Okay.
Habt ihr es gehört?
Es hat einen Sound gemacht.
Yes.
Es hat gemacht.
D.
Hat's gemacht.
Oh.
Und wir haben Farben.
Yep, Clock.
Und auch den Login-Sound.
Okay.
Settings.
Was für Auflösung haben wir denn zu bieten?
Vor allem, wer macht hier nix?
Haben wir taus...
Ah, fuck.
Wir haben kein 1920x1080?
Was ist das?
Können wir denn vielleicht mit irgendeinem gefakten Monitor dazu überreden, das zu
machen?
Monitor ist Energy Star Compliant.
Natürlich.
Was sonst?
Custom Auflösung ging damals noch nicht, gell?
Ah, vielleicht gibt's hier was mit Generic Television Plug-and-Play Monitor.
War da nicht irgendwas mit Display-Inni?
Doch.
Aber, Chatge, ich habe in weiser Voraussicht schon im Vorfeld nachgeguckt, wie das funktioniert.
Ich wusste genau, dass das ein Problem ist.
Das wusste ich schon von Windows 98.
Und ich habe mir schon was rausgesucht.
Ob es funktioniert, weiß ich allerdings nicht.
Und zwar, was würden wir ohne RecEdit machen?
Für Display-Auflösung.
So.
Und laut einem Reddit-Post, den ich gefunden habe, müssen wir unter HK-Current-Config-Display-Settings-Resolution.
Und da kann man 1920, ups, wenn man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt, mal 1080 reinschreiben.
Und jetzt soll angeblich, ich weiß nicht, wie man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt, mal
1080 reinschreiben.
Und jetzt soll angeblich, ich weiß nicht, wie man das jetzt noch richtig schreibt.
Und jetzt soll angeblich, PogExcellent.
Das ist Massive Coggers.
Full HD, Leute.
Full HD.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob das nach dem Reboot immer noch Full HD ist?
Restart.
Lass mal gucken, ob das nach dem Reboot immer noch Full HD ist.
Ist es.
Fullest HD.
Du, du, du, du, du.
Oh, Gers, Alter.
So, jetzt lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Update.
Windows Update.
Das geht im Leben nicht mehr.
100%.
Wenn das noch gehen würde, das glaube ich nicht.
Oh.
Thank you for your interest in Windows Update.
To take it, Moment.
Wir haben keine Connections to the Internet.
Was ist da los?
Moment, Moment.
CMD.
Was ist das?
IMD?
Ne, muss man damals noch ese eingeben.
Fuck.
Wie hat man damals den Terminal auf gemacht?
Accessories.
System tools.
Oh no.
Gab's nicht hier nen DOS?
Ah ja, MS-DOS Prompt, da ist es doch.
Gab's damals schon IP Confic?
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Sind wir nicht connected to the Internet?
Doch.
Wir sind mit dem Internet connected.
Umg.
Steht genau da, wir sind mit, guck, wir können Google DNS pingen.
Wir sind mit dem Internet connected.
Connect, ah ja.
Connect me to the Internet.
Okay, dead.
Hätte mich jetzt auch echt gewonnen, wenn das irgendwie funktioniert hätte, man.
Google.de
Wow.
Was jetzt?
Welcome to MSN Internet Access.
We need to install a modem before continuing.
Ein Modem?
Wait a minute.
Ich hab kein Modem.
LAN, manual.
Connect using my local area network.
Massive.
Discovery Proxy, jawohl.
Do you want to set up an Internet Mail Account?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist gut sein, Microsoft.
Finish.
Und jetzt?
Detect Proxy Settings.
Also wir sind mit dem Internet verbunden.
Okay, Google.
Mein Browser hängt.
Leute!
Google ist sowas von rückwärtskompatibel noch, dass es einfach funktioniert im Internet Explorer.
Und welcher Internet Explorer ist das?
Internet Explorer 5.5.
Snapshot?
Du meinst hiervon?
Bevor wir es kaputt machen.
Ja, guckt mal da.
Gmail.
Das kann man doch im Leben hin.
You are about to view pages over a secure connection.
Warum, jetzt, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Warum war es ein Security Alert, wenn die Sache jetzt besser ist?
Oh, Gmail geht nicht.
Ja, das ist klar, ne?
Kekke weh, Alter.
Ey.
Yes.
Immerhin.
Google funktioniert noch.
Kekke weh zeigt ein stärkeres Lachen an als vergleichbare Begriffe wie LOL oder HAHA.
Okay, Google ist super krass rückwärtskompatibel.
Oh nein, schon wieder Postleitzahl-Leak.
Und ich wohne wahrscheinlich immer noch mitten im Main, wenn wir auf Google Maps gehen.
An den Maps geht natürlich hier drin nichts, das ist schon mal klar.
So, meinen YouTube-Punkt müssen wir alle ausprobieren.
So, aber was ich...
Stimmt, wir wollten folgendes gucken.
Ob das FAT32 war, habt ihr gefragt.
Das ist FAT32.
Oh yeah.
Massive Cleanup.
Bup.
Oh.
Tools.
Oh, die Fest...
Jawoll, Leute.
Die Festplatte wird defragmentiert.
Wie lange habe ich schon keine Festplatten-Defragmentierung mehr gesehen, ey.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das verwirrt die SSD.
Unglaublich unten drunter.
Also, das wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren.
Aber man könnte die Festplatte defragmentieren.
Guck hier.
Guck mal, hier wird richtig hart rum defragmentiert.
Massive Defragmentierer.
Bup.
Do you want to quit disk...
Was ist, wenn ich sage no?
Bleibt einfach auf.
Unsinniger Dialog.
Checkdisk.
Ah, das macht keiner...
Uncensored.
Okay.
Tune-up.
Boah, ey.
So ein Schrott habe ich nie verwendet.
Warum genau?
Warum genau startet mein Control Panel nicht?
Was ist das Problem?
Bitte schön.
Control Panel wurde defragmentiert.
G-Folder.
Is null or not an object?
Okay.
Yes.
Das sieht man mal.
Das Zeug lief damals schon extrem gut, ne?
Ja.
Internet Explorer Script Error.
Okay, da müssen wir jetzt mal danach suchen.
Internet Explorer Scripts Error Control Panel.
Okay, geil.
Wir müssen...
Das war anscheinend damals schon ein Browser.
Kann man wenigstens hier in die Settings gehen?
Control...
Fuck, Alter.
Mein Control Panel ist kaputt.
Und jetzt?
Aber das funktioniert und sowas hier.
References?
Leute, wir machen das...
Das ging aber eben.
Wir machen das, was immer hilft unter Windows.
Restart.
Kann es sein, dass die Defragmentierung das kaputt gemacht hat?
Die Defragmentierung hat mein Windows zerstört.
Aber zum Glück, Chat, sehr gute Idee gewesen von euch.
Zum Glück haben wir einen Snapshot.
Das war doch vor der Defragmentierung, oder?
Ah.
Du konntest nichts klicken.
Jetzt war nichts mehr anklickbar.
Es funktioniert.
Also, merke, Defragmentierung ist eine äußerst dumme Idee.
Unter Windows ME in der VM auf SSD.
Ah ja, wir müssen...
Selbstverständlich.
Moment, Leute.
Ich muss...
Ich muss Dings installieren.
Ähm.
Avira, Leute.
Avira...
Gibt es Avira noch für Windows ME?
Naja.
Aber ich wollte euch ja eigentlich was zeigen.
Ähm.
Das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Free Hotmail.
Naja, das tut alles nicht mehr.
Das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Konzept gebracht, dass mein Windows einfach kaputt gegangen ist.
Ähm.
Ich wollte euch ja was zeigen.
Und zwar...
Wir hatten es ja ursprünglich davon, dass wenn man sich zusammengesetzt hat,
das erste, was man gemacht hat, also mit mehreren Leuten damals zusammen Half-Life 1 lokal Multiplayer oder so spielen wollte,
oder teilweise sogar Internet-Connection-Sharing machen wollte,
das ging übrigens so irgendwie.
Ähm.
Internet-Connection-Sharing?
Boah, Fuck.
Jetzt kriege ich nochmal zusammen, wie das funktioniert.
Da konnte man ja zumindest jetzt drüber ins Internet.
Zumindest...
Was ich euch eigentlich zeigen wollte, ist hier.
Du musstest damals, damit die ganzen Spiele lokal noch funktioniert haben,
musstest du erst mal hier, man kann das übrigens auch nicht resizen oder sowas,
musstest du erst mal hier reingehen,
dann erst mal in...
Das sieht irgendwie so komisch aus.
TV-Adapter?
Internet-Connection-Sharing?
Okay.
Zumindest, du musstest dann da reingehen
und irgendwo, wenn du Glück hattest,
hast du dann dein...
Deine Netzwerkkarte gefunden?
Nee.
Wo konnte ich jetzt überhaupt meine IP-Adresse einstellen?
Ah, hier.
Genau.
So, und dann musstest du erst mal unter...
Bindings?
NetBIOS, genau.
Du musstest erst mal NetBIOS enablen,
was standardmäßig nicht enabelt war,
dass manche Spiele im Multiplayer funktiert haben.
Dann musstest du noch IPX,
IPX, SPX hinzufügen.
IPX, SPX.
Dann musstest du noch
NetBOI hinzufügen.
So, und dann
konnte man, glaube ich, diesen ganzen Krempel
auch noch, musste man auch manchmal noch irgendwas einstellen.
Was habe ich jetzt hinzugefügt?
ATM-Call-Manager, das wollte ich gar nicht.
Was auch immer.
Besser als NetPlayer, ja, das stimmt voll.
So, und dann...
Das hast du beispielsweise damals für den Half-Life-1-Multiplayer gebraucht.
IPX oder...
Ich bilde mir sogar einen noch für Quake 3.
Oder vielleicht da auch schon nicht mehr.
Zumindest IPX, IPX, SPX.
NetBOI.
Und man musste sicherstellen, dass hier...
Ich weiß nicht, warum das jetzt gar...
Warum man das nicht mal einstellen kann.
Man musste einstellen,
dass man NetBIOS over TCP-IP enablen möchte.
Das war wichtig dafür.
Chatge, wer von euch weiß, wofür das wichtig ist,
dass man NetBIOS über TCP-IP aktiviert?
Vielleicht ist einer von euch noch Fivehead
und kann sich da noch dran erinnern und weiß das noch.
Ach so, Restart.
Selbstverständlich, obviously, muss restartet werden danach.
Weil UDP-Standard war.
Nee, nee, nee, das war nicht das Problem.
Du musstest das machen, weil...
Oh, guck mal.
Jetzt kriegen wir sogar ein neues Login.
Enter password for Microsoft Networking.
Sind wieder da.
Du musstest das machen, weil sonst die Netzwerkumgebung nicht funktioniert hat.
Entire network. Unable to browse network.
This may be for a number of reasons.
Oh.
Windows ist gecrashed.
Shit.
Oder nicht.
Oder doch.
Fuck.
Nee.
Doch nicht.
RitterRost, danke für den Sub.
Also, man muss...
Man musste...
Yes.
Do you use the Internet on this computer?
Direct connection to my IP...
Ja, genau, ja, ja.
Yes.
My computer...
Use the default network to MS Home.
Okay.
Share.
Nein.
Yes, create a home networking setup disk.
No.
Restart.
Natürlich.
Du musstest damals echt wegen jedem Scheiß restarten, Mann.
Hauptsache restart, Mann.
Guck mal, jetzt brauchst du auch viel länger zum Restarten.
Congratulations.
Home networking is set up on this computer.
Now run the home networking wizard on your other home computers.
Ja.
Okay, das geht immer noch nicht.
Siehste, das war echt so ein Ding.
Alter.
Das war echt so ein Ding.
Damit, damit dieses Netzwerk anzeigen funktioniert hat, da musstest du noch irgendwelche Magic-Sachen
hier enablen.
Aber ich weiß, ich weiß nicht mehr was, ehrlich gesagt.
Wisst ihr, was wir mal ausprobieren könnten?
Guck mal, neuer Ordner.
Share.
Konnte man hier schon...
Man konnte doch unter Windows ME schon Windows Shares machen irgendwie.
Aber so, aber so ging das anscheinend damals noch nicht.
Wie konnte man damals?
File and Print Sharing.
I want to be able to give other access to my files.
Yes, will ich.
Restart.
Pass auf.
Restart kommt jetzt.
Restart.
Das wird mich...
Windows, Alter.
Restart.
Oh, haben wir es gebraked?
Oh shit.
Nee.
Ne.
Wow.
Hui.
Noch mal Glück gehabt.
Ich habe schon gedacht es ist kaputt.
Das hat einen so krass fragilen Eindruck schon gemacht.
Was, beim Standardrechner kann man auch auf Cancel drücken?
Das wusste ich ja noch gar nicht.
Geil, Alter.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Man kann ernsthaft auf Cancel drücken und das Kind lockt dich trotzdem ein?
Ist das ja ganz gut.
Vishal.
poo.
Vishal, der knackige Mensch.
Das macht auch um.
Das ist ja kein Jahr an wie yerIDS confirmed.
Bis endlich.
Bis Vierf 그걸 so Paree nicht geblazen.
Und sie kann statt kencel können.
Vierf tracing.
Das ist ja geil, man.
So, kann ich jetzt meinen Ordner sharen?
Oh, oh, guck mal hier.
Share S.
Kek, wait.
Full Access.
Full Access Passwort.
Okay.
Mal gucken.
Ich bin jetzt echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Wartet mal, Leute.
Ähm, Command.
IP-Config.
Hier, die brauchen wir mal kurz.
Lass mal gucken, ob das noch von meinem modernen Windows-Windows-Stells funktioniert.
Wie funktioniert hier?
Ähm.
217.135.
Äh.
Windows?
Das hat ja einfach keinen Bock jetzt.
Alter!
217.135.
Ich glaube, das ist jetzt ein Windows-11-Problem.
Windows-11, kannst du mal aufhören, irgendwie beschissen zu sein?
Ich glaube, da kann man nicht drauf zugreifen.
Achso, sag mal, ein Support an.
Ne.
Ne, ne, hab ich nicht.
Dann geht das wahrscheinlich nicht, ne.
Konnte man hier schon sowas eingeben?
Not locked on.
Okay.
Ah!
Moment.
Not locked on?
Muss ich da jetzt?
Ah!
Kek, wait.
Übrigens, diese Dinger waren mega unsecure.
Es gibt tausende Cracking-Tools von Windows-Laufwerkshares.
Windows 11 hat die alte Samba-Version nicht mehr drin.
Okay, das ist auch.
Irgendwo sinnvoll, ja.
Dass das nicht mehr aktiviert ist.
Ja, aber hier, kek, kek, kek, wait.
Hier, ich hab mal geshared.
So, das haben wir jetzt ja schon gemacht.
So, also, alle, alle, alle Wichtige, wir brauchen...
Moment, Moment.
Appearance.
Wir müssen, wir müssen uns mal diese tollen,
tollen Windows-Themes angucken, die damals dabei waren.
Boah, wie viele Sachen da dabei waren.
Okay, es sieht, es sieht eins beschissener aus als das andere.
Wobei man sagen musste, dass man,
ähm, die, die alten Windowses und Windows XP und so,
die konnte man echt noch verhältnismäßig gut customizen.
Gerade Windows XP gab es ja jede Menge Theme-Engines und sowas für.
Aber da ist jetzt nix dabei, was ich verwenden will.
Ah, es gibt die guten...
Da hab ich mich so abgefeiert damals bei diesem Screensaver.
Da hab ich mich so abgefeiert, ey.
Das, das, das war für mich so eines der,
der, die, die, ja,
die Zukunft ist jetzt, quasi.
Mei, ja.
Und konnte man das nicht Fullscreen machen?
Ist doch, hä?
Ey, Windows.
Jetzt ist es einfach wieder zugegangen.
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen crappy war das Ganze ja schon, ne?
Maze, Settings, Size, Ads.
Ah.
Da hab ich mich echt abgefeiert damals.
Die Zukunft ist angebrochen, dachte ich mir, als ich das gesehen hab.
Wundervoll, ja.
Man sieht vor allem die Wände, die einfach nur ein Pixel dick sind quasi.
Also, null Pixel dick eigentlich.
Guckt, guckt euch die Kante, die Kante von den Wänden an.
Die ist halt quasi nur ein, oder null Pixel breit, so.
Naja, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes?
Pipes, oh, den kennt jeder, oder?
Den kennt jeder.
Den kennt wirklich jeder.
Ich glaube, das ist das Ding, Screensaver, den echt absolut jeder kennt.
Natürlich nicht, nicht so easy, sondern man musste, wenn schon, hier volle, volle Pulle.
Guck mal, man konnte hier sogar noch, guck mal, da gab es hier noch richtig Options für.
Da konnte man es dann voll übertreiben irgendwann.
Und da ist einem damals voll einer drauf abgegangen.
Dass es da, dass es da Rohr gibt.
Und da hat man die Rohre random verpiped bei einem auf dem Bildschirm.
Ohne Rohre verlegen, ja.
Und wenn das voll war, dann hat das, glaube ich, mit so einer komischen Löschanimation gelöst.
Genau, genau, genau.
Jetzt wird es gecleart und dann geht es wieder von vorne los.
Und man hat sich so abgefeiert, wie modern und toll das alles ist.
3D-Text, ja gut, das, den hatten auch manche.
OpenGL, alles klar, den hatten auch manche.
Hell yeah, Kekona.
Passiert da jetzt noch was?
Die Amis, Alter.
Die Amis, das war ja klar.
Baseball.
Blank Screen, okay.
Tech Channel.
Hui.
Ist das, ne, das ist die OEM-Version ohne Zusätze.
Kein Pinball.
Microsoft Active Channels.
Was genau soll einem das jetzt sagen, eigentlich?
Ach, da kann man mehrere Channels, was auch immer Active Channels überhaupt sind.
Ja, das war für die Noobs, Alter.
Das war für die Noobs.
Jetzt.
Läuft der GTA 5?
Ja, gewisse Ähnlichkeit hat es ja.
Dangerous Creatures.
Kann man, kann man da nicht einstellen, dass es mehr gibt?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Flying Through Space.
Ja, den hat da auch jeder.
Schon irgendwann.
Mal an.
Mit den, mit den Sternen.
Den hat auch jeder schon mal an.
Minecraft läuft nicht oder Windows ME.
Flying Windows.
Genau.
Und.
Und für die ganz Abgedrehten.
Konntest du dann sowas machen?
Falls, falls, falls du nicht genug Windows.
Inside your Computer.
Wow.
Echt?
Woher weiß der, wie es in meinem Computer aussieht?
Ach, so sieht es da aus.
Da fliegen Transistoren rum.
Ja, das ist.
Klar.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum das immer abkackt, alles.
Äh, nicht Transistoren.
Keck, wait.
Äh, Kondensatoren.
Da war, es war schon viel Schrott dabei, ja.
Dschungel.
Lass mich raten, jetzt gibt es so einen komischen Dschungel-Hintergrund-Sound.
Ne.
Einfach nur random Zeug, was aufploppt.
Leonardo da Vinci.
My Pictures.
Ah, das bin ich auf der Rennbahn.
Ganz klar.
Mystery.
MonkaS.
Nature.
Science.
Hier.
Life Science.
Oh.
Was ist jetzt?
The display driver is not synchronized with the current virtual machine display.
Press ALT-Tab to switch back to this.
Okay, irgendwas, was nicht funktioniert.
Geht auch nicht.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, da war schon echt viel Schrott dabei, ne.
Und das hier kannst du, die ganzen Hintergrundbilder kannst du ja im Prinzip auch.
Was? The wallpaper you selected can be shown on the desktop only if active desktop is enabled.
Was zum Teufel ist... Aber yes, yes, yes, active desktop, bester.
Ah, jetzt wirkt der Desktop gleich deutlich aktiver und besser.
Muss man sehen. Also ich finde, der fühlt sich jetzt gleich komplett anders an.
Active. Active Desktop, was haben wir denn hier? Was ist das denn?
My current home... Ist das Internet Explorer auf dem Desktop oder was?
Hä? Das ist ja komplett unsinnig.
Wer will sowas denn haben?
Aber guck mal, hier gibt es noch Windows ME als Internet Explorer Edition.
Customize my desktop, ja, haben wir doch.
New desktop item. New active... What?
Okay, HTTP. Google, jawohl.
You have chosen to make the site available offline and added to your active desktop.
Okay.
Wow, Widgets, Leute. Widgets waren das quasi.
Äh, was auch immer ich jetzt hier habe.
Das waren quasi so Art Widgets.
Bisschen buggy das Ganze vielleicht, ja.
Widgets. Das ist auch so ein Feature, was wahrscheinlich echt niemand verwendet hat.
Ja, jetzt ist... Ja, nice.
Jetzt ist wieder alles auf.
Jetzt ist es wieder ein ganz normaler Desktop.
Immerhin hat Microsoft damals mitgedacht und hat es einfach mit einem Klick disablen lassen.
Also disablebar machen lassen.
Und nicht dieser Shit, wie du es teilweise hast oder Windows 11, wo Sachen dann einfach so sind, wie sie sind.
Und falls euch was auffällt, guckt mal hier.
Man hat, obwohl man...
Obwohl man hier mehrere Explorer-Felder hat, hat man hier...
Man hat tatsächlich für jedes Ding einen eigenen Eintrag in der Taskleiste.
Ist ja auch ein Ding, wo wir die Technologie nicht mehr haben unter Windows 11.
Wobei ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es...
Gibt es das schon?
Gab es damals schon diese nice Utah-Wüsten-Wallpaper?
Nee.
Top mit...
Top mit das da.
Da gibt es Wüste.
Und Clouds.
Leute, jeder, der Windows 95 hatte, hatte dieses Ding.
Windows 95 Enjoyer hatte das.
Da hatten die Wolken damals alle.
Das Dumme ist, ich sehe die Maus nicht.
Wo ist die Maus?
Da.
Ah, Windows 3.11 Vibes.
Ah, wir bleiben hierbei.
Viel, viel nicer.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch schon?
Setup MSN Internet Access.
Ja, das haben wir schon gemacht.
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht mehr.
Weg.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Sachen gelöscht.
Ähm.
Was habe ich denn?
Zwei Sachen gelöscht?
Kann man nicht mehr...
Recoverness weg.
Ein New Folder habe ich gelöscht.
Wie genau habe ich es geschafft, New Folder zu löschen?
Arrange Icons.
Ähm.
So.
Damals gab es übrigens noch das gute Outlook Express.
Wenn ihr mich fragt,
war das gar kein schlechter E-Mail-Client damals.
Das war minimalistisch und hat funktioniert.
Ich meine, mittlerweile kannst du es natürlich vergessen.
Aber das,
was danach kam, diese ganzen Versuche, fand ich persönlich schlimmer.
Es gab dann erst Windows Live Mail.
Dann gab es dieses neue Mail.
Dann dieses UWP Mail.
Und ich weiß gar nicht,
hat Windows überhaupt noch ein Mail-Programm standardmäßig?
Jetzt haben wir die Mail-App.
Okay.
Unfassbar schlecht.
Was, was, was ist, was ist beim Auer los?
Das muss uns irgendwo angehören.
Drama.
You have one unread E-Mail.
Okay, zeig her.
Was haben wir dann?
Welcome to Outlook Express.
5 Hotmail.
Okay, das brauchen wir natürlich nicht.
So, dann lasst uns mal was gucken.
Und zwar,
wir haben ja gesagt, ich wollte mal ausprobieren.
Nee, Moment, jetzt müssen wir vorher noch gucken.
Nicht das Lüfter-Drama, wie sowas war.
Ich habe überhaupt nichts mitbekommen.
Wie, wie bekommt man Updates für Windows XP eigentlich?
Today we are talking about Windows Updates.
Option number one.
So we've decided to download the
Updates and install them one by one.
Ja, ich hätte gern so ein Update-Package oder sowas.
Nee, nee, da gehe ich bestimmt nicht hin.
Da gehe ich nicht hin.
Ich will die offiziellen Updates.
Option two.
Perhaps the previous option was a little discouraging.
So here we are.
To update Windows ME, we can use a toolkit, which in this context is a CD-Image that contains the offline installer packages for the individual Updates.
Wo lost?
In this context is a CD-Image that contains the offline installer packages for the individual Updates.
Archive.org has us covered with a very large archive of Windows Updates for legacy operating systems, which spans Windows 95 through Windows Vista.
Wo lost?
Assuming that you are not on a metered internet connection, we can download the 3.6 GB ISO-Image containing Updates for Windows 95 through XP.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Wo lost?
Nee, doch wo lost.
Do allow some time for the download to finish.
If you are using a virtual machine, you can mount the disk image and install it.
Okay.
Und start installing Updates.
Machen wir.
Option three.
Oh.
This is by far the simplest and least time consuming option.
Retro-System-Revival-Blogspot.com.
Das kann man doch nicht unter Windows öffnen, oder?
Consuming option.
We just need to download the unofficial service pack for Windows ME, then install it.
Trau ich mich, dass das runterzuladen.
Sounds pretty easy, right?
So, what's the catch?
Like any unofficial service pack, it's unofficial, meaning that Microsoft didn't make it.
Among other things, the implications are, the unofficial service pack has not been tested to the degree that Microsoft would have.
Naja, nicht, dass Microsoft dafür getestet hätte, oder?
And the unofficial service pack may not be complete.
Similar to filling your car with gas, how do you know the appropriate amount of gas made it into the tank?
Was?
It's very difficult to test and confirm.
The next thing is that it doesn't feel like the system has been patched.
Through the normal life cycle of the operating system, there would be monthly updates released, which would then need to be installed.
Condensing that process into a single installer package makes patching the system feel effortless.
Wo müssen wir da hin?
Option four.
In a previous video, we looked at the auto-patcher for Windows 98.
What we are attempting to do here is...
...to take a Windows 98 system that has been fully patched and upgrade it to Windows ME.
Naja, okay, also, wie heißt dieses Ding?
Oh, ich muss mal kurz meine Linux-VM anmachen, ich trau mich da nicht drauf.
Retro? Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Retro System Revival. Das klingt ja sehr vertrauenserweckend alles, man.
Und Möglichkeit zwei war was?
Wulos. Okay, das können wir auch mal probieren.
Von Archiv.com.
Ach, Archiv.org. Kann man Archiv.org aufmachen mit Internet Explorer 5? Wahrscheinlich nicht, hä?
Oh, Wulos.
Ne, wie war das?
Details.
Ah, Details Wulos.
Jaja, ich bin...
Warte, auch nett.
Kann man die Träne suchen?
Haha, das...
Search? Search?
Okay, vergiss das mit Windows...
Vergiss das mit Windows...
Was ist das? Warum geht...
Okay, ich muss meine Windows... meine Linux-Kiste aufmachen.
Wie hieß das?
Archiv.org. Wulos.
Ist doch hier.
Windows Updates for Legacy Operating Systems.
Show.
Für Vista? Ne.
Nein, ich will Windows ME haben.
Nicht 95 und Vista.
Ne, das bringt mir nix.
Okay, dann machen wir das andere.
Retro Revival Blogspot. Oder wie hieß das?
Retro System Revival Blogspot.
Und dann? Wo ist der hin?
Das klingt ziemlich einfach, oder?
Windows ME Service Pack.
Windows ME.
Ah, alles klar.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, wo wir gelandet sind.
Die Weebs sind überall, man.
Ähm, was bin ich hier sehend?
Service Pack.
Gibt es das hier irgendwie?
System Updates.
ME?
Alter, die findest du ja gar nicht.
Ach, hier, Windows ME.
After years of waiting.
A proper service pack with system updates.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das wirklich installieren will.
Alter, das ist komplett...
Download now. Mega.
Das ist ja super vertrauensverweckend,
wo man hier die Updates...
Wo man hier die Updates herbekommt, man.
Chat, ich glaube, ich muss für meine VM
mal ganz dringend
die Netzwerkverbindung gleich ausschalten,
bevor ich das da drauf kopiere, Alter.
Geht eigentlich Copy-Paste
in Windows 95 rein?
Alter!
Copy-Paste funktioniert einfach.
Einfach.
Na, einfach. Nicht.
Jagst durch Virus total durch.
Ja, okay. Machen wir.
Download now.
Wo komm ich denn hier raus?
Bei den China-Chinesen, man.
Download.
Excellent.
Ja.
Virus total.
Choose file.
Downloads, ja.
Geben.
Scheint sauber zu sein.
Es schlagen bei
vier irgendwelche random
Heuristik-Checks an.
Also, da ist...
Da ist nix wildes drin, denke ich mal.
Wissen tut man's natürlich nicht.
Egal, wir kopieren das jetzt rüber
und installieren das. Easy.
Äh.
Downloads.
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
Äh. Sort. Moment.
Äh. Arrange.
By modification date.
Um. Um.
Dings. Okay. Genau. Desktop.
Kann man das vielleicht
umbenennen? Nicht in Excel, dass das irgendwie
einfach irgendwie .keckel heißt oder so.
Vorher.
Ich kopiere sowas ungern bei mir
auf den Rechner drauf, man.
So, und jetzt. Und jetzt muss das Ganze
reinkopiert werden. Ich hoffe, man kann in Windows
ME Sachen reinkopieren.
Okay, Funds. Nice. Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Da ist es. Hier sieht man auch die Extension.
Excel.
This package is not part
from Microsoft. Are you sure you wish to...
Yes.
Ups.
Und erst mal wieder alles. Erst mal wieder alles
löschen. Ja.
Und erst mal. Und jetzt, Leute. Gleich mal.
Ich bin ja immer paranoid bei sowas.
Erst mal gleich noch. Erst mal gleich noch
Prozess Explorer launchen.
Gleich. Gleich.
Prozess Explorer launchen und gucken, was
da abgeht.
Auf meinem Host wird nichts
abgehen. Aber trotzdem.
Yes.
You must disable system file protection. Install Internet Explorer.
6. Yes.
Ich mach das.
Aber Moment. Ich hab Internet Explorer 6 nicht installiert.
You must have
IE6 install pre-autosystem update.
Äh. Hab ich nicht. Wie krieg ich
Internet Explorer 6? Man weiß es nicht.
Tja.
Krieg ich. Krieg ich das
auf der Weeb-Seite?
Was ist hier unten mit meinem Vm-Wert-Zeug los?
Gibt's
auf der Weeb-Seite?
Äh. Favori. Ja, genau.
Internet Explorer.
Oh. Internet Explorer.
6. Download. ME.
Chip.
Was? SP. Muss man SP1
inszenieren? Nee.
Aha. Kann man
das, kann man das ins, das hier
aufmachen unter?
Nein, das ist HTTPS. Nein, das funktioniert
natürlich nicht.
Naja. Ich muss keine
Chip. Ich krieg's ja nicht mal runtergeladen,
weil irgendwie.
Zip.
IE6 SP1.
Jawoll.
Gibt es da nicht irgendeinen offiziellen
Download? Irgendwas? Microsoft
WinFuture. Genau.
Das brauchen wir. Das sieht
halbwegs, halbwegs official aus, man.
Download jetzt
starten. Den brauchen
wir. Ja.
IE6 SP1
ME. Hatte, kann Windows
ME schon Zip-Dateien entpacken?
Ging das, ging das schon?
Werden wir gleich sehen. Werden wir gleich sehen.
Nee.
Fuck. Warum nicht?
Da brauchen wir WinZip, würde ich sagen.
Musik, Musik ist aus.
Da brauchen wir WinZip.
Oder, oder WinRar.
Alter, VMware. Spack doch mal nicht so
dumm rum, Alter.
Ähm.
Doch. Windows ME
kann schon entpacken. Guckt hier.
Seht ihr? Richtig
advanceder Shit.
Kann Zips entpacken.
IE6 Setup.
Diese Ordner enthält
die benötigten Info...
Kann er gelöscht werden?
Das ist nett, dass ihr... Ich stimme dem Vertrag
zu. Leute.
Ihr zahlt uns Microsoft.
Anwalt ist unterwegs.
Ich stimme dem Vertrag zu.
Sign.
Jetzt ist er den typischen Komponenten.
Gib ihm.
Das dauert wahrscheinlich länger.
Finish.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.
Es restartet einfach mal random.
Mit was auch immer für einem Hintergrund.
Was auch immer da abgeht gerade.
Ist es jetzt broken?
Nee.
Es macht noch was. Es macht noch was.
Es updated System Settings.
Warum habe ich diesen
hässlichen Hintergrund die ganze Zeit
jetzt da gehabt?
Es ist alles nicht so klar.
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Okay.
Haben wir jetzt Internet Explorer 6 drauf?
Ist es jetzt IE6?
Hey.
Es ist IE6, Leute.
Sieht Google jetzt
moderner aus?
Die Suchseite konnte nicht geöffnet werden.
Okay. Muss ich sagen.
http://he.google.de
Okay.
Mein Internet geht nicht mehr.
Ping.
Hm.
Es hat meine Netzwerkconfig zerschossen.
Nice.
Windows.
Update.
Sehr gut.
Es ging damals schon immer richtig gut alles.
Ach. Ich habe vor allem mal disconnected.
Ich kack nur.
Ist richtig.
Was ist da?
What the Windows?
Stimmt. Ich muss das Netzwerk wieder connecten.
Ihr habt Recht.
Ich habe es disconnected.
Ich glaube Windows checkt es nicht im laufenden Betrieb.
Erstmal auf Windows 5.
Ne. Warten wir mal ab.
Gehen tut es trotzdem noch nicht so wie es aussieht.
Die Proxyeinstellungen werden gesucht.
Hey.
Kack weh.
Ne. Es geht genauso wenig wie davor.
Aber immerhin.
Hier geht auch nicht mehr.
Also das Upgrade vom Internet Explorer.
Okay. Dann installieren wir jetzt mal
das super official Package from Microsoft.
What is included?
Ah ja.
Obvious.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Jetzt verstehe ich alles.
Wenn ich weiß, dass das hier included ist.
Alles klar.
Let's go.
Ich würde es ja immer noch
gerne in ein eigenes Netzwerk setzen.
Lasst mich nochmal kurz
beim installieren
so wirklich trauen durch
dem Zeug.
Was ich da am Start habe.
Okay. Unofficial update.
You must have. Ja wir haben
IE 6 installiert.
Das da haben wir.
Paint Graphics Filter.
Updates. Install updates
for Windows and Internet Explorer. Klar.
Paint Graphics Filter.
Unbedingt.
Das brauchen wir glaube ich eher nicht.
Okay.
Stimmt. Was für ein Paint haben die da eigentlich
dabei?
Ja. Das ist das Ural Paint noch.
Der Klassiker.
Was passiert?
Was passiert hier gerade?
Erweitertes Inf-Installationsprogramm.
License.
Das erweiterte Inf-Installationsprogramm
muss Windows neu starten.
Was?
Wait.
Was auch immer es tut.
Was auch immer es macht.
Oh mein Windows hängt.
Windows dead now.
Okay.
End task.
Oh.
Das ist so super fragil alles.
Und warum habe ich diesen
dummen Hintergrund gebildet?
Das habe ich doch nie eingestellt.
Warum habe ich diesen komischen Hintergrund gebildet?
So.
Top.
Jetzt haben wir das Updaten.
Inwieweit es jetzt was gebracht hat
bin ich mir nicht sicher. Aber jetzt haben wir
das top aktuellste Windows
ME was wir haben können.
Was macht
die da okay?
Ich habe den super krassen Kreiselgrind
gemacht.
Die letzten Tage.
Ich habe
zwei Alp 50er, zwei
mit 50er komplett getemplated.
Ich habe den übelsten Kreiselgrind
gestartet.
Katrin wo spielst du gerade?
Falls du Eden spielst.
Waren wir mal in Gruppe irgendwann in letzter Zeit?
Kann das sein? Der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Kann sein.
Mit 50?
Jetzt musst du erst mal gucken, dass du
gescheites Equipment an den Start kriegst
und ein bisschen Geld machen.
Oh Moment, das ist ja Toss.
Das ist ja Toss.
Am Anfang hatte ich hier unten sowas,
das nannte sich Windows Web TV.
Das ist einfach
komplett verschwunden mittlerweile, oder?
Und es ist auch,
Leute, es ist auch ein neueres
Es ist auch ein neueres
ähm, äh, Media Player
jetzt dabei, als am Anfang.
Es ist jetzt Media Player nicht
mehr 7, sondern Media Player.
Da
funktioniert nichts, man.
Ist einfach nett.
Also ich glaube, das ist schon,
das ist schon, glaube ich, nicht mal 7.
Das ist, glaube ich, schon was, was neueres.
Was?
No. Radio Tuner.
Ja, der funzt bestimmt immer noch.
Ja, ganz, ganz bestimmt.
Ja, eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich ja noch diesen
It's not your default browser.
Would you like to make it your default?
Was ist denn mein default Browser?
Wenn nicht Internet Explorer.
No. Yes?
Jetzt ist alles gut?
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt stört er sich nicht mehr drüber.
Ja, ich wollte, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich noch
Browser Service ausprobieren.
Was ist denn das noch?
Äh, GitHub Browser Service.
Wir machen auch mal hier einen
Snapshot von der Kiste. Nicht das, was wir brauchen,
aber man weiß es ja nie. Ja, Browser Service.
Browse the modern web
on historical browsers.
Releases. Wahrscheinlich das
App-Image runterladen und starten.
Gucken wir mal.
Ah, da muss ich ja wieder Netzwerk.
Was? Ich habe dich gefragt, ob es
sein kann, dass wir letztens in der Gruppe waren.
Der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ok, Downloads.
Gucken was jetzt passiert.
Wie der ganze Krempel funktioniert.
Browser Service App-Image.
Wow, what?
Verdana Font is not installed.
Oh nein.
Run Install Verdana.
Ok, wenn der das sagt.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Ich meine, ich habe eh einen Snapshot gemacht.
Ingame Name ist Pox.
So.
Und jetzt? Fonts das jetzt?
Äh, Netstat?
Minus...
8080. Ok.
Ok, Fonts. Nice.
Ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das
klappt. Geht das auch
mit meiner externen
IP hier? 8080?
Testen wir das mal von Windows aus.
8080?
Nein, das listet schon mal nur
lokal.
Wie sagt man dem denn?
Ja, das listet
auch nur lokal.
Wie sagt man dem denn, wie er listen soll?
Elb?
Achso, ich habe ja keinen T-Max.
Blog, Browser, Font, was?
Ah, hier.
Opt-HTTP-Listenport.
Kann man da so etwas wie Sternchen
vielleicht reinmachen?
Ne.
Oder 0.0.0?
Das ist ja an allem listend.
Nice, Fonts. Ok.
Ob das aus der Windows 98
VM funktioniert?
Da bin ich ja mal echt gespannt.
Äh, aus der Windows ME VM.
Gut, dazu müssen wir die Netzwerkverbindung wieder
einschalten. Gibt es Schlimmeres?
Netzwerkverbindung wieder einschalten?
Internet Explorer aufmachen?
Hä?
Ok, der
ist nicht so schnell mit Netzwerkverbindung.
Ja. Wo ist das?
Ah, das hat das wieder nicht gecheckt.
Ich habe doch gerade
die Netzwerkverbindung eingeschaltet, oder?
Ich glaube, wir müssen mal wieder
das übliche machen.
Was hilft, wenn man irgendwas nicht geht?
Warum? Wo kommt dieses hässliche Hintergrundbild
hier?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Oh, da hat noch
irgendwas geupdatet. Ich weiß nicht mal was.
Aber Hauptsache, er hat irgendwas geupdatet
im Hintergrund.
Ah.
Will now close.
So, break it, dass Google wieder funzt.
Guck mal, ob Google DNS... Ok, ja.
Ok, mein DNS funzt wieder.
Also theoretisch sollte ich gleich
ins Internet kommen wieder.
Nachdem er meine Proxysettings
detected hat.
Es funzt.
Google.de
Massive. Guckt mal.
Modernes Internet.
Lukas Podolski Döner
trendet zurzeit. Ok.
Gut zu wissen.
Herzhafte Spitzbubenrezept.
Vermisst es mich.
Also, das eskalatet
aber quickly die Suchanfragen gerade.
So, aber dass das
funktioniert. Was machen wir? Youtube?
Massive.
Qualität PNG.
Ah ne, nur kurz checken.
Ja.
Ich mein Sound geht. Aber Leute,
es funzt. Ich mein, das ist natürlich
jetzt schon Trick 17, ne.
Das ist, äh, Browser...
Und wie hieß das?
Browser Service.
Das ist nicht wirklich eine Windows 98.
Das braucht eine Kiste im Hintergrund.
Vielleicht nicht
so ganz in der Lage dafür.
Ähm, das läuft im Hintergrund
auf einer
nicht Windows 95 Kiste
mit einem Chromium
Headless, rendert das und schickt es als
Bild rüber in den alten Internet Explorer.
Ah, jetzt ist wieder hier
Bot, Botgis am Start.
Mod check.
Aber witzig, dass das funktioniert.
Keck
So, und jetzt kriegt es wieder ein Netzwerk
entzogen. Ich trau der Sache nicht.
Aber ist cool, dass
das funktioniert.
Bin ich extremly
pog. Mal gucken, ob
jetzt nach dem Neustart auch das auf einmal
funktioniert. Nein, das funktioniert immer nicht.
Und was mich auch sehr
irritiert ist, dass nach jedem Reboot
RunDLL
32 Cause and Error hat.
Moment, ich kann nicht mal rebooten?
Wait a minute, mein Reboot
ist kaputt. Darf ich mich jetzt ausloggen?
Ne.
Also ich glaube, es ist ziemlich broken, ja?
Shutdown?
Ah, das
Das ist das fucking Windows XP
Shutdown Ding.
Was ist denn das hier jetzt auf einmal?
Ne, das ist einfach das Shutdown Programm,
was mit dem neuesten Update da drauf gekommen ist.
Warte, ich kann immer mehr neu
starten, Alter.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht? Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Moment, ich will nicht die Fiber Tools reinstallen.
Nein, nein, ich hab mich verklickt.
Ich will, ich will
restart.
Das war bei SP1 dabei.
Also ich vermiss die Zeiten wirklich
nicht, was das angeht. Das ist so
pepega kaputt alles immer.
Meine Güte. Das macht
auch einen super fragilen Eindruck.
Ich mein, starten geht,
aber stoppen
geht nicht.
Ja, nice Max.
Übrigens, mal was anderes
an der Stelle. Habt ihr
gesehen, dass es weitere
vom
Rackman, dass es weitere
White
Pepo Happy Backgrounds
gibt? Hab ich vor zwei Stunden
geupdatet. Es gibt zwei neue,
es gibt zwei neue Backgrounds, nämlich
einmal
den Solder Champ
und
Recycled Story.
Es wird langsam richtig, richtig
viel hier.
Da ist ja wirklich jetzt für jeden was dabei.
Außerdem rotated es. Guck mal hier,
Nudel mit Lachs, der weiß Bescheid.
Recycled Story als
ja, finde ich auch gut. Ja, was ein bisschen
komisch ist,
kann ich denn, Moment, kann ich denn
shutdown
now?
Wie macht man
minus
R now?
Alter, wie kann man Windows dazu
überreden? Ach, jetzt geht
Neustart wieder. Okay, run DLL
32 hat sich gefixt. Man muss einfach nur auf
genug Neustarten. Problem hat
sich gefixt. Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
wie ich dieses mega hässliche
Background Ding hier weg krieg?
Es würfelt einfach, ja.
Vielleicht muss ich auch einfach
das Netzwerk einschalten
und dann hat es wieder den Fehler.
Sperrbildschirm.
Vielleicht, ja, aber wo stelle ich
das ein mit dem Sperrbildschirm?
Und warum ist es jetzt auf einmal so super
langsam beim Starten? Am Anfang war es aber
mega schnell.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Screen Saver Appearance.
Aber soll ich euch mal was zeigen? Guck mal hier.
Seht ihr das? Seht ihr das?
Ja, es buggt gerade
ein bisschen.
Man konnte einfach
Das buggt jetzt übelst
rum gerade mal vor allem.
Und wie ging das jetzt
nochmal mit dem Exclusive Mode?
Kann man nicht
irgendwo sagen? Exclusive Mode?
Ah hier, Exclusive Mode.
Man konnte damals Ordner
auf die
Taskleiste ziehen
und hätte man jetzt
hier was drin gehabt,
dann hätte es wahrscheinlich
auch funktioniert.
Ach, da ist er doch.
Hier, guck mal. Man konnte einfach
Ordner auf die Taskleiste ziehen und das ging dann.
Sachen gibt's, oder?
Man konnte die Dinger
sogar als Popout
irgendwie anzeigen lassen.
Da ist die Technologie heute auch einfach
nicht mehr da. Sollen wir uns das
noch angucken? Wir müssen uns eh noch
zwei, drei Stellen anzeigen angucken,
habe ich gerade gesehen.
Haben wir noch offen?
So, darf ich jetzt neu starten? Shutdown?
Nö.
Okay, dann keine Ahnung, was das
für Schmerzen hat.
Und was meint ihr?
Ist Windows ME jetzt so kacke wie gedacht oder nicht?
Ich muss sagen,
Windows ME war auch nicht schlechter
als die ganzen anderen DOS-basierten
Windows Systeme von davor.
Hatte durchaus ein paar ganz coole Neuerungen.
War
das so super gehasst wurde, weiß ich
bis heute nicht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlechter als
Windows 98 gewesen.
Ich meine, es ist im Prinzip Windows 98
mit ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Wurden BMPs nicht unterschiedlich?
Weiß ich nicht. Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Dann setze ich jetzt einfach mal
wieder None.
So wie es default ist.
Und jetzt restart ich und guck mal, ob dann der Hintergrund
wieder weg ist. Ach ja!
Jetzt ist dieser komische Hintergrund wieder weg.
Ist der Pinball-Flipper?
Ich glaub schon!
Ich habe gesagt, das ist die OM-Version
ohne Zusatzdinger.
Aber ich hab eben in die Settings reingeguckt
und mir war es so, als habe ich da was
von Pinball gesehen.
Nach jedem Warcraft 3-Game formatieren. Echt?
Okay.
Und warum? Hast du hier rausgekriegt, woran das liegt?
Benutz mal ME 2-3 Wochen lang.
Ich kann es doch nicht mal
einen halben Tag benutzen. Für was soll ich das benutzen?
Es ist...
Pinball ist dabei. Ja.
...
Äh,
wie hat man noch mal die Dinger bedient?
Leute! Wie äh...
Wie hat man noch mal
die Dinger bedient?
Y und M?
Nee.
Oh mein... Z?
Z und...
Okay und jetzt das andere... Alter, Z?
Ja gut, weil er hat deutsches...
...
Moment, ich drücke gerade alle Tasten durch, aber ich finde die andere Taste nicht.
Options?
Space?
Ne.
Player Controls.
Set?
Ah.
Right Flipper ist nicht belegt?
Haha, geile Default-Settings.
Geile Default-Settings.
Machen wir U, wir machen einfach U jetzt.
Ey, es funktioniert.
Hey, jetzt geht's wieder nicht mehr.
Hallo?
Das geht nicht mehr.
Das Zeug war damals schon...
Weil Tilt soll bedeuten was?
Tilt?
Was muss ich machen, wenn da Tilt steht?
Das hat meine Settings nicht benutzt.
Doch, hat's meine Settings übernommen.
Tilt is game over.
Ah, das ist, weil ich zu viel gewackelt habe.
Weil ich's dann kaputt gemacht habe durchs Wackeln.
Ah, da ist Pinball dabei.
Alter, ich bin ja der beste Pinball-Dude überhaupt, ey.
Das spielt sich irgendwie ein bisschen von allein, oder?
Und jetzt?
Ey!
Warum drückt man nicht einfach immer?
Chatge, warum drückt man nicht einfach immer beide auf einmal?
Dann kann man sich nicht vertun beim Runterfallen.
Guck, einfach immer, einfach immer beide drücken.
It's outplayed.
Ey!
Ich hab's verpasst.
Unfair.
Naja, gut.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wo der Sound hin ist.
Eben hatten wir noch Sound.
Und nochmal.
Aber wir haben, unser Sound ist kaputt.
Aber ich hab den Sound irgendwie ausgeschaltet.
Oder?
Ne, Sound, Sound ist...
Ich bin begeistert, wie gut das funktioniert.
Eben hatten wir noch Sound.
Jetzt ist der Sound aber irgendwie weg.
Und, und, wie, wie gehabt.
Und wie gehabt, sobald was nicht geht, einfach rebooten.
Und dann geht's wieder.
Pass auf.
Warum ist bei jedem Windows-Start irgendwas anders?
Jetzt muss ich mein Passwort zweimal eingeben auf einmal.
Es ist wirklich immer irgendwas anderes, egal was du machst.
Aber jetzt ist der Sound wenigstens wieder da.
Okay, nochmal restarten. Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Ich glaube, wenn ich neu starte, nur oft genug,
und irgendwann haben wir alle Kombinationen durch, was passieren kann.
Ah, das ist, wenn ich mich beim ersten Mal vertippe,
dann kommt zum zweiten Mal Passwort eintippen,
der alte Dialog wieder.
Obviously. Logisch.
Und das Beste ist, dass man Cancel drücken kann,
und es lockt sich trotzdem ein.
Das ist wirklich Monarch S, Mann.
Also sollte sich einloggen.
Vielleicht macht es auch einfach gar nichts.
Kann auch sein.
Jetzt macht es einfach gar nichts mehr.
Okay, interessant.
Ach doch.
Okay.
Also ein bisschen pepega war da schon alles im Kopf da.
Die Microsoft-Leute, die das gebaut haben.
Pictures.
Cliff in Clouds.
Guck mal, diesen Image-Viewer, den gab es mehr oder weniger auch noch unter Windows XP.
Nur ein bisschen, nur ein bisschen verbessert.
Konnte man damals auch schon mehrere Bilder öffnen da drinnen?
Nee, das war nicht im Scope, mehrere Bilder zu öffnen.
Damals hat man halt Infranview oder wie das hieß installiert.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Also so ein Image-Viewer für Windows.
Drucken. Man kann drucken.
You need to install a printer.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass...
Ah, Windows hängt.
Logisch.
Der Druckerdialog wollte sich nicht öffnen.
Obviously, dass Windows jetzt hängt.
Oder?
Ach, jetzt hängt es nicht mehr.
Alter, das ist schon ein bisschen kaputt.
Das ist schon alles ein bisschen im Arsch.
Was haben wir denn hier unten zu abwählen?
Launch Web-TV für Windows.
Ah ja.
Das funktioniert richtig gut.
Aber eine Sache muss man ihnen lassen.
Ich glaube, die Windows-Suche hat noch halbwegs funktioniert damals.
Was war jetzt?
Cannot instantiate...
Ad-Rotator.
Ja, ist ja schön, dass ihr mir keine Ads anzeigen könnt.
Winamp. Ja, Winamp ist essential.
So, jetzt habe ich irgendwas gestartet, was ich hier...
Web-TV. Kriege ich das wieder aus?
Irgendwie vielleicht so zur Abwechslung?
Ein Task-Manager.
Sah so damals der Task-Manager aus?
Ja, anscheinend.
Anscheinend.
Was Zeug, Mann.
So, wer hat eben die Stellenanzeige gepostet?
Da gucken wir jetzt noch schnell rein.
DevOps-Engineer. 80 bis 100 Prozent.
Aha.
Auch Teilzeit möglich.
Ups.
Bin ich...
Stuhl übers Kabel gefahren.
Ein DevOps-Engineer wird gesucht bei...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die aussprechen soll.
TerraActive. Active könnte ich noch...
Aber TerriActive.
Okay, also.
Blablabla.
Deine Hauptaufgaben.
Mitarbeiter bei der Plattform automatisieren.
Das passt ganz gut zu DevOps-Leuten.
Virtuelle Plattform auf VMware-Basis.
Ist jetzt nichts, was ich da klassisch bei irgendwelchen DevOps-Leuten sehen würde, aber okay.
Ausbau unseres GitOps-Workflows.
Das passt wiederum gut.
Betrieb der VX-Rail-Appliance.
Ich weiß nicht, was VX-Rail ist.
Irgendwas vor euch, aber was VX...
VX-Rail.
HCI-Plattform.
Für alle VMware-Workloads.
Mit hoher Compute-Dichte.
Okay, ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was das jetzt eigentlich sein soll.
Integration von VMware-Tanzu-Kubernetes-Clustern.
Ja, das passt halbwegs in den Bereich.
Migration von Legacy-Applikationen auf die Container-Plattformen.
Ja.
Passt auch noch irgendwie mit rein.
Solution-Design bei Interesse, auch technische Verantwortung bei neuen Kunden.
Boah.
Kontakt mit Endkunden.
Das ist immer so der Teufel, Alter.
Ist Storage?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Vielseit.
Interessiert.
Technisch versiert.
Mit Berufserfahrung als System- oder Bereitsatz-Demop-Sign-Reliability-Ingenieur.
Vertiefte Linien-Kenntnisse und Erfahrungen mit Docker und Kubernetes.
Faul, aber clever.
Das finde ich gut, dass die das reinschreiben.
Da muss man nämlich nicht so tun, als wäre man...
...supermotiviert, wenn man nicht supermotiviert ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es schreiben.
Eigentlich schreiben die das nur rein, weil sie denken so nach dem Motto, ey...
Die wollen es auf jeden Fall nicht hören.
Also, sie schreiben das rein, aber wenn sie dich fragen, ob du faul bist,
dann wollen sie immer noch hören, dass du sagst nein.
Aber es ist tatsächlich so, also ich würde das auch unterschreiben.
Die besten Leute sind die, die ein bisschen faul sind und die Sachen so
erledigen, wie auch immer sie das dann machen, aber so erledigen, dass unterm Strich
es bei ihnen danach nicht wieder aufläuft, nicht wieder auftaucht.
Darauf kannst du dich freuen.
Also, ja, finde ich, das liest sich jetzt gar nicht mal so übel.
Passt eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger dazu, weil hier könnte man sich natürlich
vielleicht ein bisschen darauf streiten, ob der Betrieb der VMware-Plattform so in den Bereich passt.
Aber an sich, ich meine, es ist jetzt nichts, was mich in Verzückung
versetzt, aber macht doch ganz guten Eindruck.
Wenigstens nicht so viel Gelaber und relativ on point, was Sache ist und auch
keine 30.000 Listen, was man haben will.
Es ist in der Schweiz, so in der Schweiz, mehrjährige, mehrere jährliche so rum.
Firmen und Team-Events, ja, das ist halt für mich kein Benefit, ne?
Das ist für mich das genaue Gegenteil, Alter, wenn ich das sehe.
Gehalt weiß man nicht.
Es ist nicht so, dass...
Nee, in der Schweiz nicht, in Österreich, gell?
In Österreich muss das, muss das dranstehen.
Gehaltsrange.
Wobei, wie ist denn das in Österreich?
Die schreiben doch dann bestimmt einfach so Sachen drin, die komplett nichtssagend sind.
So Gehaltsrange 40 bis 150 K, so nach dem Motto.
Kannst dann auch nichts mit anfangen.
Nee, das ist, ist das nicht HCL?
Das Ding hieß ja HCI.
Sagt nix aus, ja, dachte ich mir.
Ich hab's auch noch auf vom letzten, vom letzten Stellenanzeigen-Anguck-Video.
Den hab ich mir auch noch gar nicht angeguckt.
Was haben wir hier?
Bei eSolutions ein IT-Administrator.
Hatten wir das schon?
Nee, hatten wir nicht, oder?
Hättest noch eine, ja, schick her.
Eine halbe Stunde habe ich noch Zeit.
Diese Aufgaben erwarten nicht.
Du bist für die Konferenzüberwachung und Optimierung der Fireball-Umgebung verantwortlich.
Was suchen wir noch mal?
Ein IT-Administrator-Netzwerk.
Ja gut, da passt das natürlich gut dazu.
Außerdem benutzt du dir die Konfigur-Wartung-VPN-Lösung, ermöglicht somit Windows-Nutzer im Windows- und im Linux-Umfeld, okay, überwachst, optimiert Web-Applications, Fireball-Waffe, Administration-Switch, was, du bist für die Administration der Switch-Umgebung.
Dieses Wort ist irgendwie pepega.
Du bist zuständig für die Administration der Switche, das würde ich mir noch gefallen lassen, der Switch-Umgebung.
Wisst ihr, es gibt drei Switche.
Die stehen irgendwo.
Das ist die Switch-Umgebung und die machen, für alle switchen die dann.
Also, wir hängen einfach überall Umgebung dran, dann hört es sich besser an.
Einschließlich Konfiguration und Troubleshooting sowie für die, ja okay, passt auch.
Planst, implementierst und wartest die Azure-Netzwerk-Umgebung.
Ja gut, warum nicht?
Ich dachte, da kommt irgendwas von Active Directory oder sowas jetzt.
Wo zum Beispiel die Konfiguration von Virtual Networks, ja gut, das passt zu einem Netzwerk-Administrator.
Ja gut, das passt zu einem Netzwerk-Administrator.
Ja gut, das passt zu einem Netzwerk-Administrator schon dabei.
Die Verwaltung, DNS, DHCP gefunden, ja.
Also, die Aufgaben klingen sehr passend für ein IT-Administrator-Netzwerk.
Mindestens 3 Jahre Berufs-Erfahrung in der Switch-Administration.
Es wäre an der Stelle sehr sinnvoll, eSolutions, wenn ihr hinschreibt, um was für Switche es sich handelt.
Es gibt ja schon so, sagen wir mal, zwei, drei vielleicht größere Anbieter,
die öfters mal vorkommen.
Wenn man da Access-Points und sowas dabei nimmt, dann noch ein bisschen mehr.
Das wäre vielleicht nicht verkehrt zu wissen, was es für Switche sind.
Durch deine bisherige Erfahrung, blablabla, okay.
Systemmonitor, ja.
Ja, liest sich jetzt eigentlich, liest sich jetzt ganz, ganz passend.
Wenn es mich auch jetzt nicht in super Verzückungen versetzt.
Ist halt auch ein bisschen 0815, aber immerhin nicht eines von diesen Anzeigen,
die sagen, wir suchen eine ganze IT-Administration.
Wir suchen eine ganze IT-Abteilung in einer Person und bezahlen den 40k im Jahr.
So lasse ich das doch ganz okay.
Dugado, Linux-Systemadministrator, okay.
So habe ich mal angefangen.
Auch dort, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Okay, erstmal jede Menge blablabla über sich.
Unser Erfolgstool, verschiedenste Charaktere und ein gemeinsames Ziel in einem tollen internationalen Team.
Du als Linux-Systemadministrator, männlich, weiß, deutsch, in die Crew One.
Deine Aufgaben.
Also, zeig mal her.
Du verantwortest zusammen mit deinem Team alle virtualisierten Systeme unserer überwiegend KVM, QEMU.
Okay.
KVM, QEMU, KVM.
Verwaltest unsere Managed Server mit oder ohne.
Plesk ist was für die Leute, denen das am Ende vermietet.
Das ist doch nichts für die eigentlichen Administratoren dann, oder?
Du installierst, wartest und überwachst Hardwarekomponenten, Gesamtsysteme und Server.
Kleinsystem jeglicher Software?
Was?
Der Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Wo schaust du die Angebote?
Das, was der Chat geschickt hat.
Du installierst und wartest und überwachst Hardwarekomponenten, Gesamtsysteme und Server und Kleinsysteme jeglicher Software.
Hä?
Den Satz verstehe ich echt nicht.
Ich überwache Kleinsysteme jeglicher Software.
Soll jetzt was genau heißen?
Ich überwache, ob einer den Windows Calculator aufmacht, oder wie?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
So, was habe ich geschrieben?
Ich möchte eben vom Windows-Gedöns zu Linux-Admin wechseln.
Oh ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Da tritt mir einer durch bei.
Okay, was wollen sie?
Du entwickelst eigene Scripts und Tools.
Ja, das passt gut zu einem Linux-Admin.
Entwickelst mit, nee, gemeinsam mit deinem Team, bist du für die Pflege der weiteren Private-Cloud-Installation Proxmox Open Nebul.
Das habe ich noch nie live gesehen.
Verantwortlich.
Die konsolidierten Legacy-Systeme gehören ebenfalls dazu.
Du betreust den Ticket-Support zur Abwendung des Bereichs Second-Level-Support.
Okay, zumindest kein direkter Kundenkontakt.
Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Nein, zumindest nicht so oft.
Kurze Entscheidungswege.
Ausgezeichnete Entwicklungen.
Okay, Perspektiven, Oberfristen, Festanstellungen.
Homeoffice, Möglichkeiten.
Finde ich immer gut, wenn es drinnen steht.
Nach Absprache mit denen.
Das ist immer so eine...
So eine Joker-Karte.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben es zwar reingeschrieben, aber wenn es mit der Absprache nicht geht, dann wird es nichts.
Also wenn es da nicht mindestens ein Betriebsrat mit Betriebsvereinbarung und sonst was gibt zu Homeoffice, würde ich immer das als nicht existent ansehen, wenn da sowas drinnen steht.
Möglichkeit der Vereinbarkeit des Berufs- und Privatlebens.
Da können sie viel erzählen.
Wir glauben es ihnen jetzt einfach mal.
Neue und hochmoderne Büros, standardübergreifend.
Dein Wohl liegt unserem Herzen.
Unterstütz deiner betrieblichen Altersvorsorge.
Vergünstigte urban Sportsclub-Mitgliedschaft.
Jobrad, ja, das gibt es bei uns auch.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich überlegt, ob ich mir das Fahrrad nicht über Jobrad bestellen soll, das neue.
Postlose Massagen während der Arbeitszeit.
Okay, das ist nice.
Obst und Getränke.
Der Obstkorb, der darf natürlich einfach nicht fehlen.
Dein Profil.
Du hast ein abgeschlossenes, vergleichbare Ausbildung.
Du kennst dich mit Konfigurationsmanagement, Automatisierung aus.
Das wäre durchaus sinnig.
Hier die ein oder anderen Sachen nochmal zu namedroppen.
Was ihr genau verwendet, weil es gibt ja schon unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte, unterschiedliche Tools.
Also geht es jetzt Richtung Infrastruktur, Orchestrierung und Aufbau.
Sowas wie Terraform oder eher Richtung Ansible oder vielleicht noch Puppet oder sowas.
Falls die oldschool sind.
Webserverkonfiguration mit Apache Engine X.
Ja.
Also Apache mache ich in den letzten Jahren über schon einen großen Bogen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, Chat.
Aber seitdem ich, keine Ahnung, seitdem ich entweder Engine X verwende oder wenn es um Reverse-Proxy-Sachen geht mit Let's Encrypt,
Caddy, wenn es easy sein soll, verwende ich keinerlei Apache mehr.
Ich würde sagen, bei mir ist es, HA-Proxy, HA-Proxy manchmal.
Also bei mir ist es, sagen wir mal, zum größten Teil Engine X.
Gefolgt von, wenn es easy sein muss, für irgendwelche Let's Encrypt-Sachen, für Public-Sachen, da gibt es Caddy.
Oder ganz selten, wenn es irgendwas Spezielles sein muss, mit ein bisschen Loadbalancing und eigenen Health-Checks und sowas, dann HA-Proxy.
Aber Apache, ewig nicht mehr gemacht, ewig nicht mehr.
Und die Config ist auch so abartig, ich habe da gar keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Was für ein Ding, was meinst du?
Engine X Proxy Manager.
Das ist ja nur ein Web-Interface.
Was unter der Haube Engine X Config generiert.
Traffic mag ich auch nicht mehr so gern.
Traffic ist nice gewesen in so containerisierten Umgebungen vor Kubernetes.
So, wenn man irgendwelche Docker-Compose-Sachen gemacht hat, mit Tags zum automatisch Balancen drauf.
Aber die manuelle Config von Traffic finde ich zu eklig.
Und im Kubernetes-Umfeld, finde ich, braucht man es eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Dann nimmt man den offiziellen Engine X Ingress-Controller.
Wohlgemerkt den Engine X Ingress-Controller.
Nicht den Ingress-Engine X.
Nee, nee, Moment.
Man nimmt den Ingress-Engine X.
Nicht den Engine X Ingress.
Weil, PP gar Benahmung.
Nee, ein Problem hast du mit Apache nicht.
Das Ding funktioniert.
Aber die Config ist für'n Arsch.
Software-Defined-Storage-Technologien.
ZEV und ZFS.
Okay.
Ich frag mich, wann der Unterschied überschritten ist.
Ab wann es als Software-Defined-Storage-Technologie gilt.
Hochverfügbarkeits-Technologie.
DRBD.
Alter.
Das gibt noch Leute.
Das ist richtig oldschool DRBD.
DRBD ist quasi Netzwerk-Rate 1.
Um's mal so zu sagen.
Was nimmst du sonst gerne?
Kadi.
Kadi nehm ich gerne.
Aber nur wenn's ganz simpel sein muss.
Also Kadi nehm ich nur, wenn man Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate braucht für irgendeine Public-Seite.
Ja?
Wenn ich irgendeine Webseite hab, die, oder irgendeine simple Web-Anwendung,
die ein Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat braucht
und einfach alles sonst drauf gebalanced werden muss.
Für was komplizierteres taugt Kadi meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Aber dafür ist es gut.
Dann wollen wir noch
Kenntnisse in MySQL.
MariaDB Postgres.
Scripting-Kenntnisse.
Bash.
Python.
Monitoring.
Zabbix.
Eis.
Dass die...
Dass die normalerweise die Zabbix verwenden.
Ich mag Zabbix.
Ich mag Zabbix und ich mag Zabbix nicht.
Ich find Zabbix ist ne richtig coole All-in-One-Lösung.
Die leider ziemlich oldschool wirkt in manchen Bereichen gegen spezialisiertere Tools.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal die Zabbix Graphen vs. Grafana an.
Und das richtig eklige an Zabbix ist einfach die Konfiguration in das Web-Interface.
Das checkt keine Sau.
Dass man Python und Bash-Scripting-Kenntnisse braucht, find ich auch sinnvoll.
Gerade für ein Admin-Programm.
Ja?
Das ist sinnvoll.
Gerade für ein Admin macht das sehr viel Sinn.
Auch dass das da als Anforderungen drinsteht.
Also Admins, die im Linux-Umfeld irgendwas klicken wollen oder alles von Hand tippen,
kannst du eigentlich vergessen.
Virtualisierungstechnologien.
KVM.
QEMU.
Ich mein, ja man macht manchmal QEMU, aber macht zu 99% QEMU.
KVM.
Man macht beispielsweise manchmal QEMU.
Wir haben doch mal in Raspberry Pi emuliert mit QEMU.
Ja?
Hardwarebeschleunigung ohne KVM-Sachen dabei.
Open Nebula, nie was damit zu tun gehabt.
Du bist bereit...
Das haben sie ganz unten hingeschrieben.
Ganz unten.
Erst mal alles andere und dann kommt der Deal-Breaker so quasi so da.
Du bist bereit in Schichten zu arbeiten.
Montag bis Freitag...
Nein.
Bin ich nicht.
Gegen Rufbereitschaft hab ich nicht, aber gegen Schichtarbeit hab ich was.
QEMU war auch dann mein...
Mein ähm...
Qenu QVM Champ ist äh...
Lib Wirt.
Hauptsächlich.
Also im Prinzip ist es auch QEMU KVM, das ist ja alles...
Hängt ja alles sehr zusammen...
Nee, das würd ich nicht machen.
Da wär ich raus an der Stelle..
Aber sagt mal Leute, wenn man 6 bis 24 Uhr macht?
Kann man da nicht auch einfach 24 bis 6 Uhr machen?
Dann brauchst du drei Schichten, hast du den ganzen Tag abgedeckt...
So, einfach besser ausspielen.
Achtung.
So brauchst du, so brauchst du, so brauchst du ja im Prinzip auch drei Schichten.
Nein, nein, nicht ganz.
Na doch.
Doch.
Eigentlich schon.
Mit zwei kommst du nicht wirklich aus, oder?
Na doch, mit zwei kommst du aus.
Du kommst mit zwei Schichten aus.
Die müssen dann neun Stunden quasi.
Boah.
Ist schon okay.
Also ich meine, es ist keine Stellstuhlstellenanzeige.
Also bei mir ist ja immer die Grundvoraussetzung, das was im Titel steht, was sie suchen, deckt sich mit den Aufgaben.
Das scheint ja echt der Fall zu sein.
Auf Bereitschaft hätte ich definitiv, äh, auf Schichtarbeit hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Gegen Rufbereitschaft habe ich nichts.
Und der Rest, ja, ja.
Ziemlich, ziemlich Standard, würde ich sagen.
Ja, mit zu Geld steht da nichts.
Leider, leider auf der Fall, dass gar nichts dasteht, was an Kohle, was angeht.
Was ich finde, ich auch so ein bisschen.
Weil ich glaube, viele könnten die Leute richtig gut von sich überzeugen, wenn sie halt hinschreiben würden.
Leute, bei uns 80k plus, so nach dem Motto.
Aber das machen sie nicht, weil es das bei ihnen wahrscheinlich nicht gibt.
Oder, oder sie hoffen, oder sie hoffen, dass sie irgendeinen über den Tisch ziehen können, so nach dem Motto.
Hey, vielleicht mach das für 20k weniger, so nach dem Motto, ja.
Habe ich, ich habe euch ja die Story letztens erzählt.
Vor meinem Kollege, der sich beworben hat.
Drei, drei Runden im Vorstellungs-, im Bewerbungsverfahren durch hatte.
Und sie haben ihm die ganze Zeit erzählt, 90k plus, ja passt, ja passt, ja passt.
Und am Ende haben sie ihm gesagt, ja, das Budget ist leider nicht da, sie bekommen bloß 70k.
Und da hat er halt gesagt, ja, nö, tschüss.
Ich gehe jetzt wieder, macht's gut.
Gibt nichts.
Direkt wieder weg.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was sie sich denken, wenn das, wenn das Unternehmen so machen.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung.
Denken die sich jetzt, wenn du die dritte Bewerbungsrunde durch hast, haben sie sich so von dich über-, von denen überzeugt, dass du nur noch 20k weniger nimmst.
Ich sehe das komplett andersrum.
Ich sehe das so, wenn ich schon quasi, bevor ich überhaupt angefangen habe, beschissen werde, fange ich erst recht nicht an, oder?
Ich glaube, die, ich glaube, die haben da, wie sagt man heutzutage so schön, ich glaube, die haben dort das falsche Mindset gehabt.
Eigentlich müsste man dafür...
...bezahlt werden teilweise, das stimmt schon.
Wie hast du nicht das High-Performer-Crime-Set-Mindset?
Das ist aber nix.
Das hier ist ein, ein High-IQ-High-Performer-Stream.
Wir sind hier immer super High-Performant im, im Stream.
Gerade in den Streams, wo ich drei Stunden nix mache.
Wir sind immer super High-Performance.
Hyperscaler.
Siehste?
Endlich einer, der sich das gemerkt hat, was ich für ein Mist erzählt habe.
Immer Hyperscaler.
Wir sind blazingly fast.
So, Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übrigens noch einen Tipp für euch, wenn ihr ein Netflix-Abo habt.
Wenn ihr ein Netflix-Abo habt, und selbst wenn ihr kein Netflix-Abo habt, ich find, es lohnt sich dafür, mal ein Netflix-Abo abzuschließen und gleich wieder zu kündigen.
Ich hab was, was ihr euch unbedingt angucken müsst, also was mir persönlich echt sehr gut gefallen hat, und zwar...
...Blue-Eye Samurai.
Okay.
Es ist kein Anime.
Oh, ja, ja.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, so manche Ultra-Anti-Vogue-Leute sind mega getriggert von manchen Sachen in der Serie.
Aber ihr wisst, ich seh da auch einiges kritisch, und ich fand's in dem Fall wirklich gut gemacht.
Genau so kann man eine Serie heutzutage machen und moderne, soll ich sagen, moderne Themen aufgreifen, auch in einem historischen Kontext.
Fand ich mega gut.
Der Stil ist geil.
Also, der Grafik, es ist mega brutal, by the way.
Also, da fliegen die Karten.
Die Köppe und die Ärmel und alles.
Und, ja.
Aber richtig, richtig nice.
Also, wer ein Netflix-Abo hat und was nicht ganz so Cutes sehen will, kann sich das angucken.
Ich fand's richtig gut gemacht.
Ich freu mich auch sehr auf Serie Season 2, sollte es dazu kommen.
Also, es ist ja wohl verlängert, aber, ja, wer weiß, wann das dann nochmal rauskommt.
Und manchmal sind ja die zweite Season auch nach einer ersten guten Season halt kacke.
Mal gucken.
Also, das kann ich euch echt empfehlen, fand ich mega, war ich sehr positiv von überrascht.
Die Vermutung hatte ich auch schon, ja.
Wollte ich jetzt mal loswerden an der Stelle.
Also, falls ihr nicht wisst, was ihr gucken sollt.
Es ist vielleicht, es ist vielleicht nicht die richtige Serie für Familie zu Weihnachten, okay?
Also, das ist doch, also, das ist auch nicht für Kinder geeignet.
Das ist etwas zu brutal.
Und man sieht auch nackige Leute und sowas.
Also, das ist eher nix, wenn Kinder dabei sind.
Ich find's übrigens witzig, wie sich das gewandelt hat.
Früher, früher wär sowas definitiv ab 18 gewesen.
So viel Blut und Zeug, was da unter abgeht.
Mittlerweile ist sowas einfach ab 16.
Was ich gut finde.
Okay, ich geh jetzt was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis dann, macht's gut, see you.